Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, bis dahin, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, tschüss, tschüss.
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
So, ich muss gerade noch was machen.
Da, da, da, da, da, da
Exzellent
Oh, ich muss gerade noch was machen.
So, wunderbar.
Ja mal gucken, mal gucken was es heute gibt.
Bin mal gespannt.
Wahrscheinlich Müll.
Hat jemand von euch schon was gekauft?
Wahrscheinlich nicht, ja.
Ich denke die meisten haben nichts gekauft.
Das beste ist immer noch einfach nichts zu kaufen.
Anstatt was günstiger zu kaufen.
Günstiger kaufen, egal wie günstig,
ist immer noch Minus.
Am Ende.
Ich mein, außer man braucht das wirklich.
Ja, dann ist natürlich was anderes.
Wenn man sich das eh gekauft hätte.
Ähm.
Amazon hat die Smart Home Kategorie nicht mehr.
Ich hab das gerne mal so reviewed,
was da so abgeht.
Aber.
Es gibt anscheinend kein Smart Home mehr.
Ja, Lightning Deals.
Amazon Devices.
Küche.
Möbel.
Computer, Software.
Home Entertainment.
Die haben kein Smart Home mehr.
Das finde ich eigentlich ziemlich beknackt.
OLED Fernsehgegönn.
Oh nice. Pock.
Richtig Pock. So, ich muss mal kurz die Musik austauschen.
Ja, schauen wir mal,
ob SSDs mega billig sind.
Ich hab da noch die SSD hier im...
Wow.
Oh nein.
OMG.
Na, da wäre ich aber arm.
Wenn der Mini Fluxer jetzt ein Cent mehr kostet.
Das wird aber kritisch.
Aber guck mal.
Das andere ist wirklich sehr,
sehr günstig geworden.
Das andere ist um ein Cent günstiger geworden.
Plus Minus kommt das mal wieder aufs gleiche raus.
Aber ist die noch mal billiger geworden?
Ist die noch mal billiger geworden hier?
Ich glaube schon.
Ja, ne.
Kurz bisschen leiser machen.
Ja, und dann müssen wir natürlich auch gleich mal gucken,
was die chinesischen, Chinaschinesen machen.
Ja.
Wenn wir was Gutes haben,
bin ich da sofort dabei.
Wo hast du denn Smart Home?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wer es geschrieben hat.
Irgendjemand hat was von Smart Home gerade geschrieben.
Wo hast du denn Smart Home Sachen gekauft?
Amazon?
Moin, Michael. 50 Trillionen.
Massive Passwort.
Ihr erratet nie mein Passwort, Leute.
Zeig mal wieder die Cute4M.
Was ist das für ein Hintergrund?
Was bin ich da sehen?
Das ist Bing Image of the Day.
Ist das irgendwie was Traditionelles, Mexikanisches oder so?
Ich hab absolut keine Ahnung,
was das sein soll.
Die Cute4M.
Ach, Leute.
Weil ihr es seid.
Aber ich werde bestimmt nicht die Cute4M verwenden,
um jetzt bei Amazon zu surfen.
Dieser nicht mal geupdatet.
Weiß ich nicht. 1804 oder sowas.
Aber hier, für euch.
Weil ihr es seid.
Eine Runde Cute4M.
So.
Chat, sagt mir, wenn genug,
wenn eure tägliche Cute4M Dosis erreicht ist,
dann switch ich wieder um.
Reicht? Okay.
Dann.
Da mach ich wieder aus.
Okay, dann geh mal die andere vor allem rüber.
Das darf ich doch nicht reinkaufen.
Poggers.
Warum ist das so langsam?
Oh. Ai ai ai.
Was jetzt?
Warum? Wie?
Monka. Ist meine Festplatte voll vielleicht?
Nö. Alles gut.
Alles gu...
Äh.
A10G reicht.
Da kommt eh nix drauf.
Okay.
Alles klar. Vollmehr Workstation
ist einfach mal abgeschissen.
Aus nicht mehr ergründlichen Gründen.
Aber okay.
Oh man. Warum nicht?
Solange es jetzt wieder funktioniert.
Ja, wenn du Smart Home Sachen
bei Amazon bestellt hast,
gibt's da irgendwie ne Kategorie?
Nein.
Geh weg.
Nein. Alter.
Amazon.
Amazon, was los?
So nicht.
So. Also was haben wir denn bei Amazon?
Wie das die Kunden Leute sagen.
Sollte man eigentlich ein bisschen mehr Platz
bei SSDs lassen? Ach ja.
Nach...
Das bisschen Geschreibe, was ich auf
meiner Systemplatte mache.
Ist doch egal.
Okay.
Jetzt entdecken. Ich bin so
bereit das zu entdecken jetzt.
Smartphone...
Moment.
Sag mal, haben die mehr?
Haben die hier mehr Kategorien
als bei mir auf dem Hauptrechner?
Ne.
Doch nicht.
Doch nicht. Alles gut. Alles gut. Hab nichts gesagt.
Also Computer Software.
TV Entertainment.
Do it yourself. Garden.
Healthcare. Coupons.
Fashion. Toys. Brands.
Headphones. Speaker. Beauty. Video Games.
Food. Drinks. Kamera.
Baby. Pets.
Es gibt
wirklich kein Smart Home mehr.
Na das ist doof.
Da müssen wir selbst... Und einfach
Smart Home suchen will ich ja nicht. Also sprich,
das heißt wir gucken... Ja wo ist dann...
Wo sind dann... Wo sind dann... Lightning Beads.
Können wir mal gucken. Okay. Wo sind dann Smart Home
Sachen jetzt drinnen?
Sind die jetzt bei
TV und Home Entertainment?
Ne. Sind die jetzt bei...
Sind die jetzt
bei Computer und Software?
Sind die jetzt bei...
Ja keine Ahnung.
Do it yourself vielleicht?
Wir suchen einfach mal
RGB LED
Strip.
Wobei das ist nicht Smart Home. Was ist der typische
Smart Home?
Fenstersensor. Und dann gucken wir mal
was Amazon selbst sagt.
Das ist ja einschlechter als das andere.
In welcher Kategorie sind denn die Dinger? Das will ich mir hier
gar nicht angucken. Sieht man irgendwie
die Kategorie bei Amazon? Das check ich
bei Amazon nicht.
Sieht man jetzt in welcher Kategorie dieses
Produktes? Smart Home. Da.
Bäm. Home Improvement.
Home Improvement.
Müssen wir gucken.
Die Frage ist nun gibt es Home Improvement
hier? Improvement.
Nein gibt es auch nicht.
Vielleicht ist es Home Kitchen und Furniture.
Das ist richtig hängen geblieben.
Haben wir hier irgendwas vielleicht
zu bieten wo das drin sein könnte?
Hm.
Das kommt der Sache noch
am nächsten Mal. Die Do It Yourself und Tools
ist zum...
F***.
Werkzeug. Aber
Amazon UI ist schon so bisschen
1998 oder?
Aber ich glaube
Ich glaube Amazon macht es richtig, das hier ist so quasi eines der Hauptdinger von Amazon,
da kann man es nicht so machen wie, keine Ahnung, Microsoft, einfach mal in kurzer Hand
alles umschmeißen, weil das hier macht bares Geld.
Wenn die Leute hier sich nicht mehr zurecht finden, ist das bares Geld für Amazon.
Headphones, ah Juwelen natürlich, da ist bestimmt kein, Lighting vielleicht da, ne da ist irgendwelche
Barbie Sachen drin oder so, hier.
Ok, ne keine Chance, gibt es keinen Smartphone mehr.
Ich mein man könnte ja auch hier oben, aber das Problem ist, hier ist die Kategorie richtig
bescheuert.
Da findest du dann so einen Müll, wie beispielsweise Echo und sowas.
Alternate, oh da war ich ja schon ewig da mehr, ich dachte früher Altsap, das heißt Alternate,
gibt es noch irgendwer der früher dachte das heißt Alternate?
Das war so zu der Zeit, wo ich immer die ganzen Prospekte gelesen hab von so Computerzeitschriften
und wo ich quasi alles studiert hab, was es zu kaufen gab und da dachte ich es heißt
Alternate.
Die haben Smart Home Sachen gerade, Black Week, Leute wisst ihr worauf ich noch warte?
Ich warte noch auf den ersten, der irgendwie den super Vogue Artikel schreibt, Black Friday
ist rassistisch, weil ich mein man könnte ja so argumentieren, Black Friday steht für
Schnäppchen, also billig und schwarz gleich billig und deswegen instant Black Friday Rassismus,
da warte ich noch drauf.
Wobei, das gibt es bestimmt schon, ich wäre ziemlich blöd anzunehmen, das gebe es nicht
schon diese Sorte von Artikel, das gibt es bestimmt, garantiert, ich will jetzt nicht
danach suchen, wer weiß was man da so alles findet, aber gibt es bestimmt schon, Monat
Pro, wahrscheinlich, so Black Week haben die hier, guck mal, die haben nicht nur einfach
irgendwie den Tag, die haben die ganze Woche, haben die jetzt Smart Home am Start?
Auch nicht, ei, ja wo ist es denn?
Ich guck mir jetzt die Lightning Deals an, bam, Beleuchtung und Steckdosen, das klingt
doch eigentlich ganz gut, aber das ist jetzt nicht, warum kann ich jetzt hier nicht zusätzlich
sagen Black Friday Deals, warum ist das so Paynes Champing, dieses Amazon UI, das gibt
es doch schon, Amazon macht doch quasi schon einen ganzen Monat, wie gesagt, da habe ich
mich ja letztes Jahr schon drüber gelustig gemacht, als nächstes kommt das Quartal und
irgendwann macht einer komplett Black Friday hier oder sowas, es war, Patricks war klar,
dass es das schon gibt, das war klar, dass das schon am Start war, dass da schon irgendeiner
auf die Idee gekommen ist, ich bin nicht in der Lage diese Shopping Seiten zu bedienen,
wirklich unglaublich, also die haben keine Ahnung, nein, nein, nein, das waren wir jetzt
nicht, so werden wir stehen geblieben, ach ja, übrigens, die Tabs reichen, ich habe hier
noch ein paar Tabs offen, also ich denke unter 40 Tabs und 20G RAM geht das jetzt aber eigentlich
nicht, kann ich hier schön nachgucken, wie viele Chroms, ach ja, das ist ja fast nichts,
guck mal hier, meine Chroms, die brauchen ja nur 3GB RAM oder so gerade, aber da geht
schon noch ein bisschen was, eigentlich ganz schön wenig, gut, das funktioniert nicht,
gut, dann gucken wir jetzt mal, die sinnlosen Lightning Deals, die sie gerade hatten, ob
da irgendwas dabei ist in der Richtung, also irgendwas, was halbwegs sinnig ist für das,
was ich machen will, kann man das, nein, das kann man nicht filtern, ne, okay, da ist,
das müssen wir nicht durchgucken, da ist ja wirklich nur Müll dabei, dann fahren wir
doch jetzt einfach mal an, wir machen jetzt mal, Computer, Stels, Video Games, das brauchen
wir nicht, das kaufe ich mir eh alles immer nur online, da brauche ich kein, das ist wirklich
ziemlich rar, was man da anklicken kann, 2060 für 250 im Angebot verkaufen, naja, wahrscheinlich
ist das wirklich ein guter Deal, sagt denn der Preis-Champ dazu, achso, da sind die gar
nicht drinnen, ja gut, dann nicht, dann habe ich auch keine History dazu, was, welches
Armband, das da, was ist das, das sieht extrem unpraktisch aus, das ist doch stumpfsinnig
hoch, also das kann mir keiner erzählen, dass das in irgendeiner Art und Weise ergonomisch
ist mit so einem Ding, das glauben die doch selbst nicht, vor allem weil der Hund da auch
daneben sitzt und zuguckt, das glauben die doch selbst nicht, dass das in irgendeiner
Art und Weise ergonomisch ist, du darfst es dann dort alles mit einer Hand rein und raus
und dran und abfuddeln, nee, nee, nee, das ist Müll, das ist Müll, ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen, das ist für die Heimwerker, also ich stehe richtig auf ordentliches qualitatives
Werkzeug, aber das würde ich mir im Leben nicht kaufen, also vor allem im Alter könnte
ich auch ohne Probleme Heimwerker sein, aber das hier ist Schwachsinn, das würde ich mir
nie kaufen, vor allem ist das auch noch magnetisch, da platzt hier eine Hänge und es fällt die
ganze Zeit runter oder so, glaubt ihr, aber von dem Shit gibt es noch mehr, also man kann
sich eigentlich relativ einfach erkennen, dass das billiger Mist ist, weil hier kein
namenhafter Hersteller irgendwie dabei ist und sowas anbietet, alles irgendwelche No
Name, China, Chinesen und was weiß ich, tschechische Hersteller oder so, die Männerbox, alles klar,
boah, das sieht ja, wenn man denkt, das sieht billig aus, passt mal auf, das ist ja mal,
da stichst du dich im Zweifelsfall noch an sowas, das ist ja mal richtiger Schwachsinn,
nee, also wirklich, es gibt schon viel Müll, ne, ja genau, dann hast du Sachen, die nicht
magnetisch sind, das ist wirklich schwachsinnig, das ist wirklich hochgradig unsinnig, ach
wusstet ihr übrigens, dass Alu-Mutter Erbsen mit Kartoffeln auf Indisch heißt, Alu-Mutter,
das habe ich mal gelernt in Frankfurt, da war ich in so einem Indischen Ein-Mann-Kiosk
wo du im Prinzip, kennt ihr diese Kiosk-Dinger, die quasi so vollgepackt sind, dass du im
Endeffekt bloß seitwärts bewegen kannst, also ich rede jetzt nicht davon, wenn man
zu fett ist, also wo die im Prinzip auf einer Fläche, wo eigentlich ein Regal in die Mitte
passen würde, drei Reihenregale stehen haben, genau, genau, wie sag ich ja, Alu-Mutter,
also dass man das so schreibt, ne, wie man das schreibt, keine Ahnung, weißt du was,
was Alu-Mutter ausspricht, ja und das haben die uns da mal erklärt, dass das, sag mal
die Musik jetzt auf einmal wieder lauter als vorher, warum, braucht man eben was anderes
mal, geht das da unten so besser aus, genau, ok das ist jetzt so leise, dass es keiner
hört, also es gibt irgendwelche extrem billig aussehenden Mäuse, oh, na wenn das mal nicht
ergonomie pur ist, fällt euch mal auf, dass diese Maus mit dieser Maus überhaupt nichts
zu tun hat, also ich glaub offensichtlich er könnte der Unterschied ja nur kaum sein,
gibt's wirklich Leute, die damit arbeiten, ich mein, dann ist ja die, wie heißt das
Sehenscheidenentzündung oder so, das ist ja dann nicht mal weit weg, ach tatsächlich
es gibt noch mehr, das ist aber auch alles richtiger Schrott, erinnert mich ein bisschen
an den legendären Fanatec Headshot Controller, das ist eh der beste, hier, Moment wo ist
er, Zack, da, da ist er, der Fanatec Headshot Controller und um nicht zu vergessen, um jetzt
mal den Moderator zu zitieren, nein nein nein nein, der Hit, da, der King bist
du, habt ihr es gehört, wenn ihr das kauft, damit seid ihr absolut der King, wenn ihr
das habt, das sieht so unglaublich billig, so richtig billiger Rotz ist das einfach,
ganzes Video, das haben wir uns doch bestimmt schon fünfmal zusammen angeguckt, das Video,
aber wenn der Chat das will, können wir uns das auch nochmal zusammen angucken, ja komm,
das ist ja immer wieder lustig, wer in Computerspielen die Nase vorn haben will, braucht eine Top-Ausstattung
und da ist der Fanatec Headshot Controller, wer in Computerspielen die Nase vorn haben
will, braucht eine Top-Ausstattung und da ist der Fanatec Headshot Controller genau das
Richtige, das Set besteht aus einer ultra präzisen Gamer-Maus und einem High-Speed-Pad,
zusammen ein unschlagbares Team, die Maus ist super ergonomisch und lässt sich an jede
Handform anpassen, das sorgt auch in langen Gamer-Sessions für ermüdungsfreies Spielen,
sechs Maus-Buttons und ein 5-Wege Steuerrad sorgen dafür, dass sie ihre Spielfigur auch
in heißen Gefechten im Griff haben.
Wisst ihr was ich hier lustig finde, der ist noch nicht mal in der Lage das 5-Wege Steuerrad
überhaupt zu zeigen, aus welchem Jahr wahrscheinlich 2005 oder so, keine Ahnung, zeig mal, zeig
mal das 5-Wege Steuerrad, wo ist das 5, wo ist das 5-Wege, vor allem, was sollen denn
5-Wege sein, hoch, runter, links, rechts, hoch oder auf und ab oder was noch oder?
Ach und reindrücken, ok, das ist dann wirklich schon weit her geholt für 5-Wege.
Maus-Füße sorgen zusammen mit dem High-Speed-Pad für minimale Haft- und Gleitreibung für
schnelles präzises Zielen im Spiel, das leichte Kabel kommt Ihnen dabei garantiert nicht
in die Quere, das sieht aus wie das aller billigste China-Chinesen AliExpress-Kabel,
die clevere Kabelführung, fetzige Leuchteffekte mit unterschiedlichen Farben, Helligkeit und
Pulsfrequenz machen das Spiel noch rasanter, Profi-Gamer sind begeistert von den Programmier-Möglichkeiten
für Maus und Tastatur, selbst während des Spiels, auch Macros lassen sich problemlos
einsetzen, damit sind sie bei Flugsimulationen, Rennspielen und anderen Games der King, der
Fnatic Headshot Controller ist das ultimative Set für Gamer und wetten, dass er auch als
Geschenk gut ankommt, probieren Sie es aus.
Das ist so unglaublich schlecht, aber wetten, dass damals auch die Omas ihren Enkeln den
ein oder anderen Fnatic Headshot Controller gekauft haben?
Was hast du mal das von Trönungs gesehen, wie er es zusammenbaut, was zusammenbaut?
Da fehlt so das eigentliche Kontext drinnen jetzt, wer was wie, er hat einen Fnatic Headshot
Controller, nice, top, der war broken, das wundert mich bei dem Produkt ja echt nicht,
das war die Telekom, ja.
So, jetzt aber mal wieder zu ernsten Angelegenheiten, gut, die Kameras sind tatsächlich ganz nice,
wenn, da muss man mal aufpassen, wenn das die Variante ist, die nicht Cloud Only ist.
Es gibt Varianten, die sind Cloud Only und das ist komplett der Rotz, ansonsten sind
die Dinger tatsächlich ganz okay, weil das eine der wenigen Billigkameras sind, also
wir haben auch Outdoor-Kameras, ein wenig Billigkamera-Anbieter, die quasi ein normales Webinterface haben,
wo man die Kamera übers Webinterface steuern kann, die einen RTSP-Stream haben und die
man auch nicht mit irgendwelcher komischen App initial konfigurieren muss, aber die haben
mittlerweile auch genug, die Cloud Only sind, die sind billiger, aber diese Sachen genauso
wie alles andere, kannst du mal eine Outdoor-Kamera zeigen, wo ein RTSP-Stream, ja von denen hier
zum Beispiel, von denen habe ich ja zwei Stück, die sind, das ist auch billigstes China-Chinesen-Zeug,
RCL oder so, RC, irgendwie sowas glaube ich, ja sowas, sowas in der Richtung habe ich,
wie gesagt man muss nur gucken, davon habe ich zwei Stück draußen hängen, man muss nur
gucken, dass das nicht die Cloud-Variante ist, ja, also die hat RTSP und ein Webinterface
zum Einrichten, ach was haben sie denn heute, haben sie irgendwas spannendes geschrieben?
Am 25.
gestern, Leute ich sage euch, das Spiel wird nie wieder was, das ist einfach, das ist
komplett gelaufen, die Sache jetzt schon, du möchtest nämlich so eine Art Haustür-Kamera
bauen, dafür sind die ein bisschen groß, mein guck mal, habe ich schon, das habe ich
schon zugemacht, aber, so um irgendwie an die Haustür zu hängen, sind die vielleicht
ein bisschen groß, wenn die nicht direkt an der Wand hängen, dass die unter so irgendeinem
Vorsprung sind, dass nicht direkt Regenwasser drauf fällt, gibt es aber auch noch andere,
die man da nehmen kann.
Du hattest letztens den Jail-Prag für ein, das ist kein Jail-Prag, ich weiß du schreibst
es in Anführungsstrichen, aber ich muss das nochmal ganz klappen, das ist kein Jail-Prag,
das ist ein Deep-Loading-Tool, was unter der Haube einfach nur ADB, also diese Android-Debugger-Konsolen-Befehle
absitzt, nennt sich so, hier, Fire-Toolbox, ich weiß, sieht sehr vertrauenswürdig aus
und es gab mal auch eine Version mit einem Virus drin, aber das funktioniert, guck
mal, hier steht sogar, mit was es kompatibel ist, Fire 10, Fire 10 Plus 2021, also sogar
aktuelle Sachen kann man damit deploaten, ich mein, warum auch nicht, ne, das ist Android-USB-Debuggen,
das sollte eigentlich auf fast jedem Gerät funktionieren, was Android ist, bei Apple gibt
sowas ja nicht.
Auch ein Punkt, warum für Automatisierungsthemen Android besser ist.
Es ist mittlerweile schlimm, was alles cloudtechnisch am Start ist, wie gesagt, war doch Anfang
des Jahres, wo AWS-Probleme hatte, wo Leute ihre Heizung nicht richtig steuern konnten,
weil AWS-Down war und da denke ich mir auch immer, als wer so bescheuert ist, ein Heizungsthermostat
zu holen, was nicht funktioniert, wenn entweder mein Internet nicht gescheit funktioniert
oder AWS-Down ist, dann ist wirklich Kopf und Malz, wie man so schön sagt, verloren
bei so Leuten.
Brauchst du Infrarotkameras, das ist halt die Frage, ob du Nachtsicht stellst, brauchst
oder ob da Licht ist, nicht kaufen, ganz einfach, ne, aber preisleistungstechnisch ist das so
ziemlich das beste Tablet, was du dir kaufen kannst, aber ich würde Fire HD Tablets nicht
als normales daily benutzt Tablet verwenden, weil der Witz von den Fire HD Tablets, wenn
du die deploatest, ist ja gerade, dass du dich da nicht mehr mit deinem Amazon-Account
in allem einloggen musst, das Problem ist aber, dass du auf Fire Tablets keine Amazon-Apps
verwenden kannst, wenn du nicht eingeloggt bist, weil die erkennen, dass sie auf einem
Fire Tablet laufen und dann die System-Authentifizierung verwenden und nicht die In-App-Authentifizierung,
also als daily Driver sind Fire Tablets nicht der Wahnsinn.
Ja dafür ist es gut, wie gesagt, ich hab auch zwei Stück an der Wand hängen als Tablet
für Smart Home Dashboard, dann ist das gut, ja ja, da hab ich das auch für.
Ich hab noch gar nix geholt, wir haben noch nix gefunden, tja, wie gesagt, ich versteh
es auch nicht, also ich hab ja mittlerweile einige der Fritz-Dect-Dinger im Einsatz, einfach
weil das die Thermostate waren, die ich hab ja ein paar Zigbee-Dinger durchprobiert,
die funktioniert haben, der Rest war einfach Mist.
So, also Lightning-Deal-Stells, wo sind wir denn hier am Start?
Safe on Hard, was Hard, wer wie wo Hard, Hard made in Germany, ah ja, wunderbar, Hard,
und das dann so dreckig oder was, ach das ist, nein, das ist die Nano-Kupfer-Technologie,
jetzt, jetzt, jetzt versteh ich's, nee, trau mal nicht, also wenn ich FFP2-Masken will,
dann geh ich zu AliExpress, ja das Toolbox macht das Werbekram weg, ähm, wenn ich Masken
kaufen wollte, würd ich zu AliExpress gehen und dort in 200er Park kaufen, das stimmt,
das ist das Problem an den Dect-Thermostaten, die brauchen lange, aber das war für mich
nicht so wild, weil ich schalt die Dinger automatisch einmal morgens um 8 ein und dann
abends um 22 Uhr aus und ob die das 5 Minuten früher oder später machen, ist mir egal.
Okay, weiter geht's, Hard, jetzt haben wir Anker, China-Chinesen-Zeug, Anker klingt
irgendwie so, so nach europäischem Hersteller, ne, das ist aber alles, ähm, China-Kram,
da hat sich irgendein super, super schlauer, äh, China-Chinese gedacht, wir nennen das
einfach Anker, nee, nee, nee, nee, Anker, oder bring ich's jetzt durcheinander, ist,
aber nee, aber Anker ist doch, ist doch China-Kram, oder, ja, aber Anker-Kram ist gut, sagt der
Chat, Chat, ich gehe ganz stark davon aus, dass Anker exakter gleiche China-Kram ist,
wie alles China-Kramsige sonst auch, nur dass man sich den Namen besser einprägen kann,
USB-C Docking Station, nee, oh, guck mal, mit VGA, endlich, endlich kann ich meine null
vorhandenen VGA-Bildschirme anschließen, wieder, pock, pock, da hab ich ja drauf gewartet,
so, da gibt es eine Dusche, warum auch immer, ja, kann sich einfach eine Dusche bestellen,
wisst ihr, das ist auch was, wo ich der Meinung bin, dass Innovationen irgendwie kontra-, also,
nee, das will ich nicht sagen, Innovationen sind eigentlich nie kontraproduktiv, wo ich
finde, dass die Neuentwicklungen irgendwie nicht in die richtigen Richtungen gehen, du
hast so super advancede Duschen, ähm, die dann viereckig sind und sowas, das unten sieht
aus wie so ein, wie so ein Ding, wo du Pfannenkuchen wendest oder so, so ein Löffel, aber warum
genau muss eine Dusche viereckig sein, was spricht denn gegen so den guten alten, klassischen,
äh, so, so Dusch, Duschkopf, so, sowas da, oder, nee, das ist richtig oldschool Dinger
am besten noch, außer, dass es cooler aussieht, warum muss das viereckig sein, Leute finden
das schöner ich nicht, äh, ich hab keine Wandbefestigung für mein Tablet, ich hab
meine Tür-Gegensprechanlage, da kann ich das dazwischenklemmen, das ist ziemlich praktisch,
so, Mist, brauchen wir nicht, oh guck mal, ein China-Chinesen-Multimeter, für 11 Euro,
äh, ich glaube, da muss ich nicht spoilern, dass das wahrscheinlich nicht so geil ist,
ja, höchstwahrscheinlich nicht, so, dann gibt es mehr USB-Gedöns, noch mehr Dusch,
das hat scheinvoll angesagt, dass man sich jetzt Duschkörbe kauft, ah ja, das, das,
Moment, das könnte ich tatsächlich, ich könnte tatsächlich ein paar flache Netzwerkkabel
geben, aber keine 15 Meter, 15 Meter flache USB, äh, flache Netzwerkkabel, fällt jemand
spontan ein, was der Anwendungszweck ist von einem 15 Meter langen flachen USB-Kabel, also
mir fallen Anwendungszwecke ein für flache, für flache Netzwerkkabel, zum Beispiel, wenn
man wirklich mal in einer doofen Situation ist, dass das durchs Fenster durch muss, oder
dass das unter der Tür durch muss, oder sowas, aber klar 15 Meter, also mal, 2 Meter, ok,
aber 15 Meter, wieso benutzt du Chromium, ja, das weiß ich selbst nicht so genau, irgendwie
habe ich mir das, keine Ahnung, also die ursprüngliche Variante kann ich dir erzählen, aber die ist
nicht sinnvoll, weil du verschiedene Profile eigentlich im Browser anlegen kannst, ähm,
ich hatte unterschiedliche Browser für unterschiedliche Anwendungszwecke, ich habe Chromium für
mein privates Gesurfer, ich habe Chromium, äh, ich hab, ich weiß nicht, ich habe Chromium
für mein privates Gesurfer, was ich so mache, ich habe Chromium für Business, geschäftlichen
Kram, und ich habe Firefox für YouTube-Krempel und Sachen drumherum, dann habe ich eine ganze
Weile noch Vivaldi installiert, kennt jemand Vivaldi als Browser, finde ich eigentlich
relativ nice, oh Leute, soll ich dir mal sagen, wisst ihr, wer angefragt hat, für, ob wir
ein Placement machen können, ihr werdet, ihr werdet nicht drauf kommen, wenn es um Browser
geht, OperaGX, genau, das sind nämlich die einzigen, die permanent anfragen, das wisst
ihr, nein, OperaGX, aber ich hab keinen Bock, OperaGX Placements zu machen, oh ne, ne, hör
mal bloß auf, ich will kein OperaGX Placement machen, ok, aber guck mal, 10 Meter sind teurer,
ah, die sind nicht Black Friday, die sind Black Friday, wie sieht das, wie sieht das
bei solchen Kabeln eigentlich aus, mit Shield, also mit diesem Aluzeugs, was da drinne ist,
normalerweise, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das Aluzeugs ist, weil normalerweise ist es ja
so, du hast die Kabel jeweils zwei Stück miteinander verdrillt, und darum hast du dann jeweils
noch mal so Folie, und das kommt dann, das ist dann, ich mein, das wird hier auch funktionieren,
aber ich stell's mir schwieriger vor, hier sowas reinzukriegen, Raid Shadow Legends
Placement, ja, irgendwann mach ich auch Raid Shadow Legends, aber die müssen noch ein
bisschen was drauf legen, egal, brauch ich nicht, so, weiter geht's, Chat sagt, wie ramschig
Amazon geworden ist, es ist, finde ich, bei Amazon, ja, also, das Problem ist, bei Amazon
gibt's schon durchaus sinnige Dinger, aber es ist mittlerweile einfach 90% Trash, und
du findest gar nichts, man guckt mal hier die normalen Seiten, wenn man hier mal guckt,
das ist ja absolut nicht normal, wenn man, ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich hin klicke, Shop
All Deals, ja, so, wenn ich hier hingehe, das sind 167 Seiten, guck mal, ich darf noch
nicht mal auf die letzte Seite klicken, die wollen, dass ich durchklicke, ich darf nicht
einfach sagen 100, wenn das sind mehr als 167, wenn man dann ankommt, man muss übrigens,
das ist, bei Amazon vermute ich da komplett Taktik, man muss immer runterscrollen, dass
man es sieht, und ich weiß, der Chat war mal richtig clever und hat rausgefunden, was man
hier oben eingeben muss, damit man auf die nächste Seite kann, nee, kannst du nicht,
das weiß ich aber nicht mehr, ich mein, wir können das mal vergleichen, so, Index 253A180,
aha, 2531, okay, das sind immer in 60er-Schritten, immer in 60er-Schritten, machen wir hier
hinten einfach mal 2000, guck mal, was auf der letzten Seite rauskommt, nee, 34, okay,
was ist bei 8000, wir haben es gleich, Leute, wir haben es gleich, 10.000, Leute, wir sind
weiter, ach nee, 10.000 geht nicht, Moment, ist das deswegen beschränkt, weil es nur 4-stellig
geht vielleicht, kann das sein, dass das letzte, die letzte 4-stellige Sache ist, ha, ich
glaube, das supportet einfach keine 5-stelligen Nummern, oder, nee, aber das ist ja alles
Crap hier, so, wir müssen das irgendwie filtern, das ist totaler Müll, wir gucken jetzt einmal
kurz die Lightning Deals durch, ob da irgendwas Gescheites dabei ist, man kann, richtig,
das ist mein Problem, ich wollte Smart Homes, also, was man bei Amazon machen kann, was
ich auch lange Zeit nicht wusste, was aber schon einiges hilft, ist, man kann hier oben
Black Friday auswählen und dann kann man zum Beispiel suchen einen L.E.D.-Strip, Alter,
was ist denn jetzt los, das hilft, das Problem ist jetzt, was du nicht machen kannst, ist
sagen, ich hätte gerne Kategorie Smart Home und dann alles Black Friday, das ist richtig
großer Müll, wie das Amazon gemacht hat, was ist das, ah, ah, der Enthülsen, oder,
ein, ah, ein, ah, nee, nee, irgendwas, was kein Mensch braucht, irgendwie so Oldschool-Zeug,
so, jetzt haben wir irgendwelche komische, wo ich mir nie merken kann, Inbus, Inbus,
die auch immer Schlüssel, aber von irgendeinem komischen Lehrsteller, von dem ich nirgends
von gehört hab, ah, die üblichen China-Chinesen-Sticks, Leute, das sind sie wieder, ich hab letztens
erst, ich hab letztens erst gesagt, hier, guck mal, und das sind sie wieder, endlich,
die Klassiker, die China-Chinesen-Klassiker sind wieder da, 4G, 1G, 1G, nicht zu verwechseln
mit 5G oder sowas, 4G, also, jawoll, 1GB, endlich, endlich, aber alternativ gehen die
auch, das Problem ist nur, mehr als 4GB ist eigentlich unsinnig, weil, weil, die Dinger
sind so langsam, also, die sind, die sind langsamer als USB 2.0, die machen irgendwie,
keine Ahnung, 56K-Geschwindigkeit oder so, das ist der langsamste Schrott-USB-Stick,
den, den, den, USB-Stick, den ihr euch vorstellen könnt, ich hab davon ja mal, kann ich jetzt
ja mal erzählen, ich hab davon ja mal eine Packung gekauft, einfach weil es die richtig
günstig gab, und dann hab ich mal so eine Packung mitgenommen, also, ist das hier eine
10er-Packung, hab ich so eine 10er-Packung mit auf die Arbeit genommen, ja, oder 10er-
oder 20er-Packung, ich glaub, ich glaub 10er-Packung, hab ich so eine 10er-Packung mal auf die Arbeit
mitgenommen, als bei uns ziemlich die Kacke am dampfen war, und hab ich gesagt, wisst
ihr was, ich nehm einfach mal ein paar USB-Sticks mit, wir brauchen bestimmt USB-Sticks, so,
und wir mussten dann unsere SSH-Keys und alles mögliche austauschen, und wir haben dann
gesagt, hey, weißt du was, lass mal unsere Public-Keys einsammeln, dass man die ordentlich
signieren können und in die CA-Eintrag, also, CA-Signieren können und sonst was, und da
sind wir rum und haben versucht mit dem USB-Stick SSH-Public-Keys einzusammeln, und das sind
ein paar Kilobyte, die Datei, und das hat ohne Scheiß 5 Minuten teilweise auf ein USB-Stick
kopiert.
Das sind, das sind 30 Kilobyte, 30 Kilobyte, 5 Minuten, das sind wirklich die beschissensten
USB-Sticks, die ihr euch vorstellen könnt, ich hab noch gar nichts gekauft.
Lieber Private-Keys einsammeln, ja, Kappa HD 4K, ja, das sind aber 10 Stück, Mark G-Plays,
das sind 10 Stück, im Vergleich zu einem anderen, ein USB-Stick, und für so Sachen, wo man
verteilen muss, ist das ganz gut, deswegen sind das immer sehr beliebte Werbegeschenke.
Ja, guck mal, hier haben wir noch so gehabt, ach nee, das sind die PoE, Moment, das ist
die PoE ohne WLAN, ohne WLAN, ja, das ist jetzt eine, das ist Geschmackssache, ob man,
die Kameras über PoE-Kabel oder WLAN betreiben wird, ich hab meinen über WLAN, weil ich
keinen Bock hab, Sachen durchs Fenster zu legen.
Der Akimbo USB-Stick, der da, der ist USB-C und normales USB, an dem ist, der ist nicht
wirklich Akimbo.
Ich frag mich nur, sag mal, das und das, das sind doch wieder zwei, ach Moment hier, ja,
das ist aber nicht nur die Farbe, was sich hier unterscheidet, ne, was passiert dann
eigentlich, wenn man beides gleichzeitig einsteckt, ist dann irgendwie Riss in der Raumzeit oder
was ist dann?
Andriesen, danke für den Sub, Leute, ich muss ja eben grad nochmal checken, ganzen
Subs, ich hab mir die Hälfte übersehen, voll lauter Big Stonks Shopping-Kram.
Andriesen, Dankeschön, Calv auch am Start, nee, Rest hab ich zu, ach, ich hab zum Glück
nicht viel übersehen, gut.
Explodiert, ja, das Gefühl hab ich auch, dann ist MonkaS Smoke angesagt.
Ah, yes, Gekommnet Fotos, Chain Law wieder, man, das ist der USB-Stick, was ist das?
100 Watt USB-Charger, ja, mittlerweile geht einiges drüber oder über USB-C.
Das sind 20 Volt, nee, doch, oder, das geht rauf bis zu 20 Volt, 5 Ampere, ja, das sind
ja 100 Watt, also da geht schon einiges, es gibt ja mittlerweile sogar proprietäre USB-Dinger,
die glaub ich bis zu 200 Watt oder 250 sogar gehen.
Andersrum, nee, USB ist normalerweise 5 Volt, ja, das stimmt, aber Quick Charge und Power
Over USB ist glaub ich bis zu 20 Volt, weil 20 Ampere willst du nicht über die dünnen
USB-Ederchen machen, ich glaube es sind 20 Volt, 5 Ampere, ja, brauchen wir aber auch
keiner, billige Werkzeugkasten, die auch keiner braucht, Monitor-Stand, den keiner braucht,
ich weiß nicht mal, was das ist, sind das Rauchmelder, ich weiß nicht mal, was das ist,
ja, das sind Rauchmelder, braucht man nicht, Mini-Rauchmelder, irgendwie eine komische
USB-Tastatur, RGB, Bluetooth-RGB-Tastatur, die mal Hardcore unergonomisch aussieht, wunderschöne
Gegenbogen-Hintergrund-Beleuchtung, okay, das ist natürlich das Allerwichtigste, also
die Tastatur kann Schrott sein, aber, das sieht aus wie ein Stein, ist das ein Stein
mit Tasten drin oder, irgendwie aus dem chinesischen Steinbruch, einfach Steine genommen und Tasten
reingemacht, ja, das ist alles unglaublich unsinnig, na guck mal, ein Nass, vielleicht
könnte ja tatsächlich mal was Gescheites dabei sein, Terra Master, okay, es ist bloß
ein Gigabit Nass, wenn es jetzt ein 10 Gigabit Nass wäre, dann wäre das wahrscheinlich
richtig nice, Plastik in Stein-Optik, gut, das würde ich mir nicht kaufen, Vorschlag,
Twitch Chat kauft für mich ein, nee, nee, das ist eher so DrBeast, nee, nee, nee, DrBeast,
MrBeast, Alter, MrBeast-Challenge, mein Twitch Chat kauft für mich ein, okay, was das,
das könnte was Gescheites sein, ist es aber nicht, das ist so ein bisschen an VR angelehnt
von der Farbgebung her, ist es aber nicht, ist es Kekuffe, Leute, der weltbekannte Hersteller
Kekuffe, okay, vielleicht der wirklich bekannt, ich kenne ihn zumindest nicht, so viel Schrott,
Mini Tastatur, Smoke Detector, fährt, einfach, ist der Hersteller fährt, okay, der Hersteller
ist wirklich fährt, sagt mir nichts, aber bei Pfeilen kenne ich mich auch nicht aus,
mein Gott, es gibt ja so viel, das sind nur die Lightning, die, hallo, Windows, ich möchte
da gerne reinklicken, darfst du nicht, nein, jetzt, also es ist schon unglaublich, wie
viel Müll, NFC-Tagsticker, kompatibel mit dem iPhone, ja, deswegen kosten die auch extra
viel, es gibt eigentlich keine NFC-Sticker, die nicht mit dem iPhone kompatibel sind,
aber man kann es ja mal hinschreiben, ich dachte schon, da steht Blockchain drauf, hätte
ich nämlich mal gerne die Erklärung gehabt, was NFC auf Papa mit Blockchain zu tun haben,
sehr interessantes Video hier, Redstar OS Installe, das haben wir uns doch schon mal
angeguckt, okay, Müll, Müll, Müll, wir machen das jetzt mal ein bisschen schneller, Müll,
Fake Drehmüll, Müll, Müll, schon wieder so ein Kack, Müll, stopp, woher sind das
Bügeleisen, sind das Aufsätze, ach nee, das sind Schleif, Schleif, Stellzdinger, komisch
geformtes Bügeleisen, ein billiges Multitool, Müll, ich hab mal den Fehler gemacht so ein
billiges Multitool zu kaufen, richtiger Reinfall, hab ich nicht einmal benutzt, weil es so crappy
ist, das sind ja mal besonders stylische USB Kabel, die sind vergoldet Leute, High Speed,
das ist, dass die Gaming Mouse noch schneller ist, wenn man sich den Fanatec Headshot Controller
gekauft hat, dann sollte man den am besten darüber anschließen, vergoldene Kontakte,
uiuiui, aber die sehen tatsächlich ganz cool aus, also das ist was, wo ich mich tatsächlich
aus irgendwelchen mir jetzt nicht ganz einleuchtenden Gründen dazu hinreißen lassen würde, weil
die machen den Eindruck, als sind die wirklich relativ robust, stabil verarbeitet, ach guck
mal, das sind unterschiedliche Längen mit den Farben, das ist tatsächlich gar nicht
so doof, das finde ich an sich tatsächlich gar nicht mal so doof, dass du hier drei verschiedene,
also ne, also stimmt ja gar nicht, fünf verschiedene Längen hast, Chat sagt die sind hässlich,
manche im Chat sagen aber auch die sind gut, weißt du, ich finde die eigentlich optisch
ganz nice, ist das China-Chinesen Kram, lass mal kurz gucken, was auf der Karte stand hier,
Volutz, hab ich noch nie was von gehört, kennt ihr Volutz, in search for brilliant, Volutz.com
hab ich noch nie, Volutz, hab ich noch nie gehört, die wahrscheinlich besten USB-Kabel
der Welt, ja, die besten USB-Kabel der Welt, jetzt wollen sie es aber wissen, oh fuck jetzt
habe ich zu, die probiere ich jetzt aus Leute, ich kaufe mir ein Set von den besten USB-Kabeln
der Welt, bam, achso, wie man kann das nicht adden, wenn man nicht eingeloggt ist, dann
kaufe ich mir das halt nicht, Frage, echt, wer hat eine Frage, Chain-Lore, gebated oder,
hast du, ja benutze ich aber nicht, hab ich mir mal geholt, einen, als ich mir dachte
hey, so für entschlüsseln und, also Festsystem Vollverschlüsselung und sonst was, benutze
ich aber nicht, weiß nicht, hatte bisher noch keinen Bock das zu machen, ist das ein echtes
Point, also es, Leute, es gibt Produkte, da ist es nicht förderlich sie mit weißem Hintergrund
und solcher Beleuchtung zu fotografieren, weil man erkennt einfach gar nichts, gut das hat
man in China beim Ministerium für Webdesign, natürlich kann man auf so individuelle Schicksale
keine Rücksicht nehmen, so und das ist jetzt ein was, ein 4C, kein 5G, Leute, die sind
euch, die sind nicht so weit, anstatt 5G haben die nur 4C, ok, brauchen wir nicht, ja sieht
aus wie einer Tendenhalter, stimmt schon, ach guck mal, ich dachte erst, das ist eine
Axt, das ist ja auch so ein maximales sinnloses Tool, oder, das braucht man, ok, ok, Moment,
Moment, was, das ist quasi Extended Taschenmesser, das soll uns wirklich springen, das ist so
ein Hammer, eine Axt, das ist eine Axt, das ist vorne eine Axt, machst du Faxen, mach
ich dich platt mit Axten, das ist, oh Gott, was ein Stuss, das ist eher so was, was man
sich in Schaufenster hängt und sich cool findet irgendwie, ok, das ist ja, ok, eine
Axt, ein Nussknacker, oder Flaschenöffner, oder wie auch immer, also so zum drehen, ein
Nussknacker, eine Axt, ein Hammer, eine Säge, eine Pfeile mit Säge, einen Kreuzschlitzschraubendreher,
irgend so ein komisches Multifunktions-Tool und ein Messer und das da oben erkenne ich
nicht, was ist das da oben, ah, das ist für, das ist zum zusammendrücken, das ist die
Zange so quasi, was ein Blödsinn, wenn irgendjemand sowas schon mal in der Hand gehabt hat Leute,
sag mal, ich gehe nicht davon aus, weil das sieht für mich hochgradig sinnlos aus, ich
kann mir nicht, also change my mind und für 13 Euro ist es bestimmt der absolute, ja,
da bist du auch ein paar Pro-Gamer in der King, noch mal billige China-Chinesen-Kameras,
pinke Headsets, Zack, ist das, ist das flashbar, nein, sieht ein bisschen aus wie die Kogi-Steckdosen-Leiste,
das ist aber nicht flashbar, wir wissen, nicht flashbare Steckdosen-Leisten kommen mir, nicht,
nicht in die Tüte, mir muss das alles geflasht werden, ja, aber auf jeden Fall, also wenn
ich mir irgendein Multifunktions-Ding dann wahrscheinlich auch so ein, so, next, was
haben wir sonst noch, oh Warnwesten, das kann man tatsächlich mal gebrauchen, nicht, dass
ich mir jetzt ein paar Warnwesten holen würde, aber das ist wenigstens mal was sinnvolles,
Müll, Müll, ist das Laser-Cutter oder was ist das, ah ne, so ein, so ein China-Chinesen-Gravur-Gerät,
ob das so eine gute Idee ist, ohne jegliche Schutzvorrichtung drum herum, ich würde fast
sagen, du willst, dass dir das ins Auge strahlt, oder, also, das ist irgendwie weird-Champ,
aber auch schlechte Bewertung, Finger weg, denkst du in Chinesisch, scheint ein absolut
Top-Produkt zu sein, wenn man die Zip-Datei entpackt, wird ein Verzeichnis mit chinesischen
Zeichen erstellt, tja, halt Müll, gut, next, gleich gucken wir nochmal bei den Chinesen
nach, der Chat wieder, Alter, sag mal, gibt es Leute, die das wirklich kaufen, es sieht
ja nicht so aus, früher, jetzt nicht Boomer-Stories, gar nicht so lang früher, also, wenn Amazon
da Lightning-Deals hatte, das waren meistens, sag mal mal, so zu 20-30% davon, wenigstens
wirklich brauchbare Dinger und die waren immer mega schnell weg, aber hier ist ja gar nichts
davon brauchbar, guck mal, für den FFP2 nicht mehr reicht, der kann sich jetzt FFP3 holen,
Frickscope-Brille, die 5000 USB-Hubs, die niemand benötigt, komische Mini-Kamera, was,
Moment, wat, wat, wat was, wa, wa, hä, warum und wollen die mir wirklich erzählen, dass
sie da nicht reingefotoshoppt ist, die liegt doch da im Leben, guck mal, das ist ihr Kopf,
Die passt doch da im Leben nicht rein oder ist sie nur als 30 groß?
Okay anscheinend passt man das doch auch gefotoshoppt alle
Was ist denn das?
Legit foto leute
Ist das für leute ohne beine oder was?
What the fuck?
Okay das kann ich mir jetzt vor der länge noch irgendwie vorstellen
ist das
haben die alle keine beine?
Oder ist da ein loch im boden oder was?
Oder ich verstehs einfach nur nicht
Ist da ein loch im boden oder was?
Keine Ahnung
Kein Schimmer was das sein soll
Wie sind denn die Bewertungen?
Tatsächlich die Bewertungen sind sogar noch ganz gut
Aber eher für kleine Menschen
Das hab ich mir fast schon gedacht
Ich bin mir auch schon mal eine kleine größe
Braucht man alles nicht?
Handtuchhalter?
Gibt es auch was geschehen?
Wir gucken gleich bei den chinesen
Ich mach schon mal hier Aliexpress auf
Vielleicht haben die chinesen irgendwas zu bieten
Wir hatten immer gute zusammenstellungen
Mydeals hatte glaube ich was
Waschina Gadgets gucken wir auch nochmal
Ob es da irgendwas spannendes gibt
Black Week
Haben wir jetzt auch alles müll
Brauchen wir nicht
Ich weiß nicht mal was das sein soll
Teppichmesser klingen oder so
Nochmal Pferd
Pferd hatten wir jetzt schon ein paar mal
Irgendwas undefinierbares
Mehr USB Stecker
Und Kabel und Hubs
Es ist unglaublich Leute
Wie viel Müll da einfach nur dabei ist
Da war nicht eine Sache jetzt wirklich dabei
Wo ich gesagt hätte
Oh ja, das ist wirklich nice
Das will ich haben, was sind das für Lightning Deals?
Waffling
Okay
Jetzt sind wir mal mutig
PC und
Seymour
So
Do it yourself
Und
Computerstells
Nee, nicht Computer, Hard
Computers und Software
Was?
Warum
Warum sind da irgendwie Kinderspielzeuge dabei?
Sieht das wirklich
Okay, Computerstells
Okay
Hier gibt es RGB-RAM
Das ist schonmal wichtig
Die Deals sind irgendwie
Kacke, ja?
Das Einzige was ich
Eigentlich fast jedes Jahr bei
Deals kaufe sind SSDs
Aber hier gibt es RGB-RAM
Dafür hat sich schon
gelohnt
Einfach noch wieder, wo ist der RGB-RAM hin?
Da ist der RGB-RAM, endlich mal
RGB-RAM
Jawoll
Jetzt das Wave-Race, das kann durchaus sein
Das ist Wave-Race Musik, ja, das ist Wave-Race Musik
Pock, Wave-Race
Das ist auch richtig nice
Das wäre durchaus mal was fürs Hintergrund
Musik für irgendein Video
So, Müll, Müll, Müll
Aha, aha
Nee, doch nicht
TP-Link
Tja, das Problem bei TP-Link
Smart-Home Sachen ist, dass die
oftmals diese komische TP-Link App brauchen
Und deswegen ist es halt
auch nicht so
geil ist
Die haben eine lokale API, machen da
immer ziemlich viel Heckhack drum herum
Deswegen traue ich den nicht
Nur für echte Gamer, ja
Samsung, da haben wir
schon
Fire TV Cube
Warum gibt es jetzt einen Fire TV Cube?
Das ist, wenn es der
Fire TV Stick nicht mal cuttet
quasi, dann kommt der Fire TV Cube
So viel
Schrott
Der Cube ist die nächste Dimension
Meinst du nach Stick?
Ja
So, ist das die?
Ja, ok, da können wir mal gucken
Amazon Basics
Das lohnt sich tatsächlich manchmal
Amazon ist ja richtig gut
im Kopieren von Produkten
Auch wenn man das ihnen wahrscheinlich
nicht so rechtlich nachweisen kann, dass
da eben ein Hersteller was machen kann, aber es ist schon
verdächtig, welche Produkte auf einmal
zufällig Amazon Basics sind
Aber das lohnt sich
Ach guck mal, hier noch mehr
USB Hubs, die hatten wir schon ganz lange nicht mehr
Ach guck mal, wieder
Wieder die komischen billig
China-Chinesen-USB-Sticks
Mein Gott, das ist so viel Schrott
Ein Arduino-Set
Leider finde ich es unsinnig
gerade mit Arduinos rumzuhandeln, wenn man
einfach ESP's nehmen kann
Ok, wir gucken mal bei
bei Electronics
gucken wir mal, was da irgendwas
Gescheites dabei ist
was wir brauchen können
Moment, ich dachte da sind jetzt Bastel-Bastel-Kram
oder so dabei
Batterien
Projektoren
Ok, ich bin wirklich überfragt, was ich bei Amazon
gucken soll, dass ich irgendwas finde
Ach guck mal, wieder so komische
Stealth-Bomber-Router
Die WhatsApp-SIM
Moment
Es gibt WhatsApp-Handytarife
mittlerweile
Ja, wusste ich nicht
Ja Leute, ich bin da nicht so auf dem aktuellen
Stand, was Handytarife und so angeht
Aber mir war das nicht bewusst, dass es
WhatsApp-SIM-Karten und WhatsApp-Handytarife
gibt. Aber gut, man lernt ja
nicht aus
Ach guck mal
Die rote Pest aus Berlin ist auch am Start
Also ich hab ja selbst
Zeug von denen
Ich hab die Bezeichnung nur vor
20 Jahren oder so mal
in irgendeinem Forum gelesen und seitdem finde
ich das irgendwie lustig
für AVM
Der WLAN-Mesh-Repeater
Tja, aber
nichts Spannendes dabei
Taucheranzüge, oder was ist das?
Oh, so viel
Schrott, man
Wisst ihr, ich glaube, es wäre fast
sinniger
Also Amazon, es ist ja egal,
was ich glaube. In der Regel liegt
Amazon richtiger als ich, weil Amazon
richtig viele Big Brain
super bezahlte Leute haben, die sich da drüber
Gedanken machen
Aber für mich
als jemand, der da kaufen will
wäre es glaube ich einfach besser
Die würden sich die 50 besten
Deals raussuchen und die dann einfach da
drauf hauen und gut ist
Dieses riesen
Wulst-Dings hier
Wüster
quasi so Ikea-Wühltisch
mäßige Zeug
Das finde ich einfach nur ermüden
Das will ich mir gar nicht alles durchgucken
Außerdem kann ich direkt bei den China-Chinesen kaufen
Doch alles nix hier
Komm schon wieder, schon wieder
Die gleichen China-USB-Sticks auf zwei Seiten weiter
Ne, das waren wir jetzt zu
Wir gucken jetzt nochmal kurz hier, was TP-Link am Start hat
Aber von denen will ich eigentlich gar nichts kaufen
Ich würde bloß mal kurz durchgucken, ob da irgendwie
Smart-Home-Stalls dabei ist
Moment
Powerline-Wi-Fi-Mesh
Widerspricht sich das nicht irgendwie?
Entweder ist es
Powerline oder ist es
Wi-Fi
Oder ist das Wi-Fi, was über
Powerline quasi weitergegeben wird
Dass du quasi
Äh
Keine Ahnung
Im Erdgeschoss so ein Ding hast
Und im Keller und das verbindest du dann
Über Stromkram
Also
Wi-Fi
Aufer Kabel sozusagen
Ne, ich hab wirklich noch nichts Gutes gefunden
Es ist zum größten Teil einfach nur
Müll
Außer die Switch-Bots, die kann ich wirklich
Jedem empfehlen
Das hab ich aber auch schon letzte, äh ne
Dienstag war das glaube ich
Empfehlen
Wer
Bisschen in Richtung Smart-Home unterwegs ist
Und Geräte hat, die sich partout
Nichts
Automatisieren lassen
Introducing
The Switch-Bot
All die Klappe
Ähm, da sind die Switch-Bots
Alter, Amazon und
Video-Qualität
Guckt die Drücken für euch
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Bäm, das sind so, das sind
Quasi WLAN Schalter
Also eigentlich sind es Bluetooth Schalter
Guck mal
Und das ist wirklich nice
Das ist wirklich nice
Für Geräte, die sich nicht so einfach
Automatisieren lassen
Ne, so gehts mir nicht, ich kauf nicht mal Sachen
Die ich nicht wollte
Ich kauf gar nichts, ich find's einfach komplett
Schwachsinnig, was es im größten Teil gibt
Hey guck mal meine Maus
Warum hat Amazon meine Maus?
Ich dachte nur ich hab die
Das Shox ist am Start
Ja, das ist ne gute Maus, vor allem in Kombination
Mit dem
Wireless-Charging-Pad
Also das ist ne gute Kombi, da bin
Ich froh, dass ich mir die gekauft hab
Ich hab jetzt, ich hab ja dieses
Ich hab ja die Maus plus
Ne Maus-Pad, was die Maus auflädt
Du hast doch mal in einem Overwatch Video die Maus
Geflamed, ne ne, nicht die
Die G502 hab ich in einem Overwatch Video
Geflamed, weil die zu fett ist
Und die G502
Ist auch, also die alte
Ist auch fett und schwer
Die ist gut
Die wiegt fast nur die Hälfte von der alten G502
Wie der Schalter heißt
Switch-Bot
20 Euro, grad bei Amazon
Kann ich wirklich jedem nur empfehlen, sich 2,3 zu kaufen
Wer da
Mit Automatisierung da was übrig hat
Das Wireless-Pad
Funktioniert, glaube ich
Nur mit Mäusen, wo du unten
Dieses
Ladeding austauschen kannst
Weiß ich nicht, ob das für die G703
Funktioniert
Wenn es da so einen Einsatz gibt, wahrscheinlich schon
Nix, ist nur Müll
Wir gucken jetzt gleich mal bei den Chinesen
Ob die was besseres haben
Ok, das brechen wir jetzt mal ab, das ist nur Müll dabei
Also bei den Mäusen war jetzt auch nichts
Das Saturtix
Boah, das ist ja mal hier richtig
Ausgefallenes Teil
Oversteel
Das sieht aus wie eine Mischung aus
Steel-Series und Alienware
Aber es ist Oversteel
Hab ich auch noch nie gehört
Können fast ein China-Hersteller sein
Der bei Gaming Hardware mitmischen will
Kenn ich nicht, kennt ihr Oversteel?
Ich hab von Oversteel noch nie was gehört
Also eine Mischung aus Alienware und Steel-Series
Oversteel
Asus ROG
Ich kann mir jetzt nicht helfen
Aber dieses Foto
Macht keinen
Allzu krass hochwertigen Eindruck
Oder?
Ach, gegen Ausfransen
Geschützte Nähte
Ach, deswegen haben sie es
Ausgefranst, weil es gegen Ausfransen
Geschützt ist
Oder wie? Also das Foto lässt das Produkt
Nur wirklich nicht gerade im
Besten Licht dastehen
Ich weiß nicht
Gaming Mousepad
XXL
Habt ihr, chat mal eine Frage
an euch, habt ihr eure Tastatur
auf dem Mousepad stehen?
Oder nicht?
Also habt ihr so einen riesen
Mousepad, wo auch die Tastatur drauf steht?
Ne
Ne, ich auch nicht
Also ich, ich auch nicht
Ich hatte das mal
Vor der aktuellen
Maus, aber ich weiß nicht mehr
Es hat mir irgendwie nicht gefallen
Ich mag das lieber, wenn meine
Tastatur auf
Ups, nicht mehr
L-A-U, oder?
Auf dem Tisch steht
Keine Ahnung
Keine richtige Abstimmung
Wir müssen doch nicht für alles
irgendwelche Polls machen
Deine Verlobte
hat das, ist sie irgendwie richtig
krasse Pro-Gamerin, oder?
Ich dachte nur die richtigen
Hacker-Mans und Pro-Gamer
haben das
Ist das F-Zero-Musik?
Ja, beste
Richtig Cat-Jam
Ja, das ist auch ein Problem
was ich hatte
Da hab ich jetzt gar nicht dran gedacht
Hacker-Gamer
und Pro-Gamer
Nice hier
Hacker-Grill
Ja, das Problem
hatte ich auch
Habe ich jetzt sogar mit dem Mousepad
Nur, dass man das schneller mal kurz
abwischen kann, ja das stimmt schon
Mousepads fangen ein bisschen
Staub und Krümel und so
Okay, da ist nichts dabei
nichts dabei
Okay nur Müll, schauen wir mal bei den China-Chinesen
was die so am Start haben
Oder was
Was empfiehlt uns denn MyDeals
heute?
Handy-Vertrag
Nein, eine MicroSD
mit 400 GB
Speicherplatz
Also, ganz im Ernst
Okay, ich
Ich denke schon wieder falsch
Ich denke sofort an meinen Raspberry Pi
Weil dafür finde ich es unsinnig
Für Kameras, wo man nicht einfach
SSDs dranhängen kann
mag das vielleicht sogar sinnvoll sein
Aber für meine Raspberry Pi Zwecke
würde ich einfach eine SSD
dran machen und dann hätte ich auch nicht
das Problem, dass man die Karte so schnell kaputt
macht
So, ansonsten
The Deal Highlights
Die haben
einen Twitch Stream
für Deals
Was läuft denn da?
Tatsächlich?
Das ist ja
fast schon
Tele-Shopping
Okay, dann zeig mal
die Highlights der Redaktion
Ja
Ne
Jetzt verstehe ich nicht, wo sind denn die Highlights
der Redaktion jetzt?
Warum soll ich die raiden? Ich bin doch nicht mal fertig
mit meinem eigenen Stream
Okay, nichts dabei
Ne, ich weiß gar nicht, was das sein soll
Ninja Black Friday?
Ach, Reiskocher und so, meine Güte
Ne, brauch ich nicht
Messerset, brauch ich nicht Uhren, brauch ich nicht Messerset
Roller, brauch ich nicht
Lego Basic Blade, brauch ich jetzt so mal
auch gerade nicht
Ein LG OLED
Ist das den, den sich der
Chat gekauft hat? Ich sage jetzt
der Chat, weil ich nicht mehr weiß, wer es ist
Aber irgendjemand hat vorhin gesagt, der hat
sich einen OLED Fernseher gekauft, ist das der?
Was haben die da eigentlich drauf mittlerweile?
Was hat LG?
Was haben die für einen Smart TV
Betriebssystem da drauf?
Ist es immer noch dieses Firefox US
basierende?
Ich glaube, LG war das doch, die
Firefox US hatten
WebOS
das Firefox basierte
Mann, nicht, dass ich es brauchen würde
Mit meinem Sony
Fernseher eigentlich ganz glücklich
Und ich bin auch niemand, der alle
2 Jahre neuen Fernseher kaufen muss, weil ich
nur Cine so gut wie nie
Die Basis ist auf Qt
Ah, exellent, das heißt C++
Das bedeutet schon mal, das Ding ist
komplett nicht
wartbar
Also ich würde keinen Fernseher auf
C++ Basis kaufen
Weirdchamp
Das stimmt
Ich habe auch schon Qt C++
verwendet, das ist deutlich erträglicher als
normales C++
Vor allem, weil
Anna
Womanizer, alles klar
Vor allem, weil
in Qt die
Klassen, die dabei sind
irgendwie Sinn ergeben
Also beispielsweise die Standard Collection
Klassen, die ergeben irgendwie Sinn
im Vergleich zu den normalen
C++ Dingern
Ok
Also wenn ich Dieter Bohlen sehen
Werbung macht für irgendeinen Mobiltarif
Da weiß ich schon mal, was ich definitiv nicht kaufen werde
Ein Makita Bohrhammer
Ok, da taugt wahrscheinlich was
Letztens habe ich Werbung im Radio, glaube ich
war das, wo ich gerade Mittagessen war, gehört
jetzt Makita Bohrhammer
kaufen
oder irgendwie sowas
Sicher dir den Makita Bohrhammer
Da habe ich mir so gesagt, ja klar, der
Nein Schlagbohrer
haben sie gesagt, sicher dir den Makita
Schlagbohrer oder Akkubohrer
oder irgendwas, da habe ich gesagt, ok
Weil die ja auch nur einen haben
Die haben bestimmt 50 verschiedene
Das ist so richtig nicht
sagende Werbung gewesen
Das ist ja alles Mist, man
Absolut Wodka
Endlich, endlich
was für uns dabei
Absolut Wodka
Wodka ist ausverkauft, ja
Ok
Auch nichts dabei
Was haben denn die China-Chinesen
Wir gucken jetzt erstmal
erstmal so die Übersicht
Was sagt denn China Gadgets zu
Lenovo
Chaoxin
Pad Plus
Nein, Leute ich kaufe mir niemals
wieder ein
Lenovo Tablet
Das eine was ich hatte war kompletter Schrott
Und ich kaufe mir auch nie
wieder ein Asus
Android Tablet, die haben mich richtig
gebadet
Asus hat gesagt, hey cool, wir haben ein nice Tablet
Ich habe das gekauft und es wurde ein
Monat später eingestellt
Hat nie Updates bekommen
Das sollte man eigentlich
verbieten, sowas
Auch wenn ich nicht fürs
Warten bin
Aber sowas sollte nicht sein
Kommt ja eine Update-Flicht
Ja, das werden die Hersteller
eh geschickt umgehen
Du kriegst dann Updates, aber da ist
bestimmt nicht drin geregelt, dass du eine
regelmäßige Betriebssystem
Major-Version Releases bekommen musst
Da steht drin, ihr müsst eure Sachen mit
Sicherheitsupdates oder ihr müsst
versorgen mit
4 Jahre versorgen
Was da drin steht versorgen
Was dann wahrscheinlich heißt, man muss die
Sicherheitslücken fixen, aber keine Major-Updates
machen oder so
Print 3D
Multifilament Modul
Das ist tatsächlich cool
wenn man keinen Drucker braucht
der mehrere Filamentspulen unterstützt
sondern das quasi so
on the fly ändern kann, wobei ich
meine Zweifel habe, dass es so gut funktioniert
Sicherheitsupdates
reichen doch, naja Sicherheitsupdates
sind das absolute Minimum, was wirklich
verboten sein soll, das nicht anders zu machen
aber
ich möchte Major-Versionsupdates haben
Weil du über kurz oder lange sonst das Problem
gibt, dass es wieder Apps gibt, die sagen
ja wir unterstützen nur ab dieser Version
Das erste, was mir so einfällt
ein Anycube E3 Mega S
kommt mir doch bekannt vor, das ist mein 3D Drucker
Guck mal, ich hab damals noch
ein bisschen mehr für bezahlt, der ist
ganz ok, wobei ich mir jetzt
eigentlich einen anderen kaufen würde
Ein Akkusauger
SwitchBot
Ah nee, der Vorhang-SwitchBot
Switcher
Das haben wir schon
gemacht
Roborock S7, den kann man nicht
Flaschen
Goovy Glide
Endlich RGB
Hat jemand von euch eine Smartwatch
und verwendet die für irgendwas anderes
außer Sportkram
Also für Sportsachen verstehe ich das
Aber für was ist eine Smartwatch
gut außer Sportkram
Home Automation
Ok, das kann ich mir auch vorstellen
Benachrichtigung, SMS lesen, aber da kann ich doch aufs Handy gucken, oder?
Zum Schlafen
Was genau bringt einem
die Smartwatch um besser zu schlafen?
Ach nee, nicht um besser zu schlafen, zum aufzeichnen
Wie gut man schläft, oder was?
Pebble
Pebble habe ich auch bei uns auf der Arbeit
damals ein paar mit rumlaufen sehen
Die Vibration
Stört es nicht am Abend, wenn man damit schläft?
Ah, Steuern auf dem Klo
Das ist eine gute Idee, das könnte mir gefallen
Die Musik
Ahja
Das ist die Musik, die hier komisch piepst
So
Da ist nichts dabei
Also
Was hat ein AliExpress Schönes zu bieten?
Gibt es dieses Jahr wieder ein Geschenkvideo?
Äh, so viele Ideen habe ich da ehrlich gesagt nicht
Muss ich gestehen
Guck mal, es ist Black Friday, deswegen ist die Seite komplett rot jetzt
Leute, ich habe Angst da drauf zu klicken
Bei AliExpress ist immer so
Also, wenn ihr denkt, bei Amazon ist schon Schrott dabei
Dann wartet mal AliExpress ab jetzt gleich
Da kommt da auch mal wieder ein bisschen
Okay, AliExpress Kram am Start
Die offizielle Auswahl
Entleben Sie die beliebtesten Artikel des Jahres?
Moment, haben die mittlerweile jemand, der halbwegs Deutsch übersetzen kann?
Ich meine, offizielle Auswahl ist jetzt vielleicht nicht so, wie ich das nennen würde
Aber das liest sich nicht mehr so holprig wie sonst
Ja gut, da sind ja auch die offiziellen Bildchen da
Die anderen Dinge sind immer noch kacke übersetzt
Man kann sich Drohnen kaufen bei AliExpress
Für 23 Euro
23 Euro
Also
Nennt mich ein Daub da, aber
Ich habe irgendwie so meine Zweifel, dass die sonderlich geil ist
Ja, MyDeals hatten wir doch gerade geguckt
MyDeals, da war doch gar nichts Großartiges jetzt
Ach, Moment, wir haben Highlights gemacht
Aktuell
Was ist aktuell?
Ein Ferrari-Pizza-Maker-Pizza-Ofen
Oh
Brauche ich nicht
Quarantäne-Kaffeemaschine
ZonoSwan
Ich weiß, dass es nicht Quarantäne heißt
Bevor der Chat jetzt wieder sagt
Max, das heißt Quadrante
Was lieber bei Heiß gucken
Okay, wir gucken bei Heiß
GachiBuzz
Ein WQHD-Monitor, nice
Ah nee, du hast gewartet und es gab keinen
Verstehe, verstehe
Moin Joghurt
Horl
Was?
Ich weiß gar nicht mal, was das sein soll
Horl 2
Es ist nicht Horl 1, es ist Horl 2
Bevor ich jetzt anklicke, Chat
Ich darf das jetzt sagen und schlau sein
Was ist Horl 2?
Du hast Horl 2, nice
Ein Messerschärfer
Ach so
Dalotajohn.de
Ein Messerschärfer
Okay
Jetzt
Wenn man das weiß, dann
So
Messerset
Fetish Gaming Recht
Ganz schön teuer, oder? Na gut
Es ist eine 3080 drin
Der muss teuer sein
Reli
Rc
Alles klar
Ice
Moment, ist
Ice nicht dieser Dildo Shop?
Zack
Oh nee, ich trau mich nicht drauf zu drücken
Ich trau mich nicht drauf zu drücken
Wer weiß, was dann wieder kommt
Torz, ja
Ich klick da lieber nicht drauf
Wer weiß, wer weiß
Nano
Bluetooth Stick
Okay, es gibt wirklich Leute, die das kaufen
Ich weiß gar nicht, wozu ich das brauchen soll
Wenn ich Bluetooth Stealths mach
Remote, nehme ich einen ESP32
Ansonsten nehme ich meinen Raspberry Pi, wozu brauche ich einen Mini
Nano, Bluetooth Stick
Ach so, mein Mainboard hat auch Bluetooth on Board
Ansonsten
Sehe ich gar nicht
Panne
Hörer
Eine Ruhr Top Card
Bands Classic
Ah
Das war es für mich
Dass man seinen Blutdruck richtig kontrollieren kann
Nee, brauche ich nicht
Ich habe ja schon eins
Zum Glück habe ich keine Blutdruckprobleme
Ich weiß noch
Das war witzig
Als ich bei meinem Hausarzt war, meinte er
Das ist schon ein bisschen her
Er meinte zu mir nach dem Motto
Ja, wir sollten mal Langzeit Blutdruck messen
Weil ich gesagt habe
Ich habe immer Kopfweh
Ich habe gesagt, hä, warum
Ja, wir nehmen Blut ab
Wir machen Langzeit Blutdruck messen
Und da bin ich wieder hingekommen
Und wir haben uns die Sachen zusammen angeguckt
Da hat er sich dann so die
Das Log vom Blutdruckgerät
angeguckt
Und die Ergebnisse aus dem Labor
Vom Blut abnehmen
Und hat sich dann so die üblichen Dinge angeguckt
Dann hat er gemeint
Ich dachte bei Ihnen wäre mehr
Also das ist zum Glück alles in Ordnung
Also er hat mich angeguckt
Der hat ja auch irgendwie sowas gesagt
Mit Ihrer Statur hätte ich gedacht
Das wäre mehr oder sowas
In der Richtung
Gut, aber ich habe immerhin irgendwie glaube ich 5 Kilo
Seitdem abgenommen, nicht dass ich das jetzt wirklich
So viel ausmachen würde
So
Und
Da habe ich zum Glück keine Probleme
Ich weiß ja woran das
Mit dem Kopfweh liegt
Mittlerweile habe ich es ja auch im Griff
Das war erstens viel zu wenig Bewegung
Und
Wenn man ein bisschen so
Nacken- und Rückenübungsstells macht
Das ist viel, viel besser
Leute ihr dürft es nicht vergessen
Ich gehe auf die 40 zu, kann man sich kaum vorstellen
Ich mir selbst auch nicht
Ich bin 37, sitze hier abends vorm Rechner
Lest Chat
Und sagt dabei
Poggers 5 head big brain move
Kennt ihr jemand anderes
Der auf die 40 zugeht und sagt
Poggers 5 head big brain move
Ok, der Krieger vielleicht
Wobei ich weiß nicht ob der sowas sagt
Ansonsten fällt mir niemand
In diesem Alter ein
Dieses GIF ist eh
Das ist das beste GIF, Alter
Ich muss mich da jedes mal wegschmeißen
Das hat bestimmt wehgetan
Aber wie im Einfaches eine komische Wand
An den Kopf fällt
Also angefangen mit Youtube
Habe ich glaube ich mit 25 oder so
Und jetzt mache ich das seit
Keine Ahnung, irgendwie 12 Jahren oder so
Kommt ja fast hin, jetzt bin ich 37
Richtiger Boomer, sage ich doch
Das glaubte mir die Leute immer nicht
Doch doch
Youtube ist sogar noch älter
Ich war noch gar nicht mal einer der ersten
Damals als ich auf Youtube angefangen habe
Waren die Außenseite voll angesagt
Und Hair Tutorial und sowas
Die machen heute alle nichts mehr
Wobei weiß ich gar nicht
Gibt es die überhaupt noch
Nicht dass ich das jemals großartig geguckt hätte
Aber das war damals voll angesagt
Ach ja mit dem Fabian nehme ich vielleicht
Am 24. was auf wieder
Ja passt doch Patrick
Du hast mit 15 angefangen die Videos zu schauen
Bist jetzt 27, das passt doch
Ey, danke für den Sub
Der Thorsten meldet sich
Genau
Der Thorsten meldet sich zurück
Wusstet ihr eigentlich, dass der Fabian jetzt
Tattoo Model ist in Dresden
Angeblich hängen da jede Menge
Plakate rum wo der Fabian drauf ist
Habe ich erfahren dadurch, dass mir das
Jemand in die Kommentare geschrieben hat
Und dann habe ich beim Fabian mal nachgefragt
Habe ich gesagt, hä was schreibt der denn da
Und dann meinte ich, ja das ist so
Also wenn ihr in Dresden wohnt
Gibt es da anscheinend irgendwelche Plakate
Mit dem, ne Facebook Werbung war es glaube ich
Oder?
Oder Plakate Facebook Werbung
Wo der Fabian Tattoo Model
Kann man das irgendwo sehen
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob du das sehen kannst
Aber ich kann das wahrscheinlich sehen
Wie lange du mir folgst auf YouTube
Ich sag euch mal wie es ist
Der Fabian, also der
Frazier, hätte der damals
Seinen Fitness Beauty Channel weiter gemacht
Der wäre heute der größte
Männliche
Fitness Beauty
Nicht Fitness, aber so Beauty
Wie nennt man das so
Fitness Beauty Channel
Weil
Der hat das Aussehen dafür
Der sieht an sich ja schon gut aus
Hat dann super trainiert, ist immer gepflegt
Und er hat vor allem
Ahnung wegen Friseur
Und er kann gut labern für die Videos
Also ich glaube
Niemand hätte einen besseren Beauty Channel
Machen können als der Fabian, aber er hatte kein Bock
Was ich auch verstehen kann
Weil YouTube ist halt
Eigentlich ziemlich kacke
Und da hat er keine Lust drauf gehabt
Der größte
Fitness Lifestyle
Beauty Channel wäre der heute
Sag ich euch
Genau Patrick, das wäre der perfekte
Lifestyle Beauty YouTuber gewesen
Klar, der Dialekt, den interessiert doch kein
Und außerdem redet er gar nicht so richtig
Krass sexisch
Hat der Friseur Onlyfans?
Nein
So haben wir sonst noch irgendwas spannendes hier
Massage Kissen
Oh, das hier ist für die
Richtklassen DJs unter uns
Und bei DJs
Heute ist mein MC glaube ich
Machst du Faxen mach ich dich platt
Mit Achsen
Hat er die Sachen auf seinem
Instagram?
Da ist er wirklich halt magisch
Auf seinem Instagram
Kann ich noch gar nicht
Mach ich jetzt nicht auf
Das ist ja schon fast halb Toss
So was haben wir sonst noch zu bieten
Wahoo Bolt
Irgendein Navigationsgerät
Aber ich hab von Wahoo
Noch nie was gehört
Das könnte fast ein Mario Sound sein
Wahoo
Aber doch, das ist bestimmt China-Chinesen Hersteller
Hab ich schon nie was von gehört
Achso
Ok, es ist doch kein China Hersteller
Es gibt einen Helm
Call of Duty
Endlich, endlich ist es reduziert
Jetzt kann ich es mir kaufen
Ich warte schon die ganze Zeit drauf Leute
Progress
Endlich, jetzt kann ich
Skill-Based Matchmaking in neuster
Ausgabe genießen
Net Limiter
Den Shit gibt es immer noch
Ok, das ist glaube ich wirklich ganz gut
Aber ist mir trotzdem zu teuer
Eine Refurbished PS4
Was?
Hundefutter
Ok, da ist wirklich alles dabei
Ein Audiointerface
Das könnte tatsächlich ganz brauchbar sein
Wobei ja Behringer
Immer so ein bisschen belächelt wird
Von den ganzen Audio-Pros
Vanguard ist SBMM nicht so schlimm
Wirklich?
Kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen
Nespresso Kapseln habe ich keine Maschine für
Brauche ich nicht
Ok, ich brauche irgendeine andere Musik Playlist
Oh ja
Chat, es ist soweit
Ok, ich bin schon mal
Wir haben es geschafft
Wir sind zum besten Nintendo Song
durchgekleckt
Okay, genug
Exquisite
Das ist fast schon wie Musik ja ist echt so
Okay, weiter Nike Air Max
Filament 3D Drucker der alpha cool Eisbär hätten sie auch gleich Knut nennen können
Orange Box
Eine güte gibt es ja nicht irgendwas was ich kaufen will
Irgendwas
Irgendwas egal was irgendwas wo ich sag hey das ist cool das will ich haben
Okay das habe ich ja schon super geil
Also ich habe das das komplette set mit tasche und so drumherum
Das ist ja nur so ein einlage ding
Oje was ist hier los ach das ist gar kein echtes bild das ist ihm
Powerwave Gorilla Handelsschälen Scheiben meine Güte
Das ist Yoshi Story Musik oder
Anni
Okay, es ist ja wirklich nur mist ich muss jetzt bei den China Chinesen gucken was die am start haben okay
Laura Laura Tab wird es über Laura gesteuert oder heißt es einfach nur so
Das liebe ich ja immer an Aliexpress du klickst eine sache an und es kommen zig tausend verschiedene andere dinge die damit überhaupt nichts zu tun haben
Wir empfehlen ach Wi-Fi aber es heißt Laura na super super intuitiv wieder
Also Aliexpress zeigt mal her was das kam RGB stellts alles klar
China Chinesen Tablet stellts ich weiß nicht was es überhaupt sein soll moment
Manga Marker das ist doch was für euch chat
Guck mal
Ich bin so glücklich
Ops, wo ist das zugemacht?
Moment den konnte man noch flaschen hier oder
Ob der ich mir ein
Die bist ja bei mir kommen nur geflashte sachen hinzufahren
oder was ohne China
Und der was der dampf
Table jetzt immer jetzt sinnt am start hier
Asus ROCK, ne gar kein ROCK, ohne ROCK High Drive, 1TB gratis
Switch, light Teleskop Sattelstütze, wann gibt's denn irgendwas
was ich haben will Berlin zwei Nächte, ich wird nicht mehr
geschenkt nach Berlin. Ich weiß Berlin hat viele Fans, aber ich fand Berlin nicht so
sonderlich dolle. Ich war aber auch nicht oft da, aber es hat mir gereicht. Da muss ich nicht
hin. Da kann ich auch nach Frankfurt. Also ich muss euch sagen, es ist erstaunlich, wie sehr
ich mich daheim gefühlt habe am Berliner Hauptbahnhof, wenn ich Frankfurt Bahnhofsviertel
gewöhnt bin. Echt so. Ich bin rausgegangen, also erstmal was mich in Berlin übelst überfordert
hat, dass ich nicht wusste an welchem Ausgang vom Hauptbahnhof man raus muss, weil irgendwie
nix da steht. Du kannst ja links oder rechts raus. Ich hab keine Ahnung gehabt wo jetzt was ist. Und
das erste was ich hatte, ich geh raus und mich hustet eher ein Obdachloser an. Da hab ich mir
gedacht, das ist ja wie in Frankfurt. Hier geht es schnell wieder weg. Aber ich will wieder
heim, wieder heim. Dafür, also eine Sache, die ich jetzt persönlich ganz cool in Berlin fand,
man kann das Kulturprogramm relativ schnell machen. Also ich war ja schon ewig her,
wo ich das letzte Mal da war. Das war so ein Battlefield 1 Event. Wann kam Battlefield 1
raus? 2015 oder 2014 oder so? BF1 Release? 16, 16. Das ist 5 Jahre her. Das Battlefield 1 Event
war ich da und auf der, also quasi am anderen Tag als das Event vorbei war, einen Tag danach,
haben wir Kulturprogramm im Schnelldurchlauf gemacht. Brandenburger Tor und dann zum Hauptbahnhof
gelaufen. Fertig, das reicht. Ja 5 Jahre ist das her. Ich kann mich da auch nur noch dran erinnern,
weil wir waren da alles dabei. Der Mesh war dabei, der Lost war dabei, der Egg war noch dabei.
Man weiß, ich glaub irgendwie ein Mega Quest oder so war noch. Ich krieg das gar nicht zusammen.
Ich weiß nur noch, deswegen kann ich mich da noch dran erinnern, wir haben so einen super
dämlichen Witz gemacht, als wir zum Brandenburger Tor gelaufen sind und du hast ja da ganz viele,
der Chimpanzee war da nicht am Start. Du hast ja da ganz viele so Regierungsgebäude und Botschaften
und so mit Flaggen und da haben wir noch irgendwie so einen richtigen Pains Champ Witz gemacht,
so von wegen hier Conquest Mode, Capture the Flag oder irgendwie sowas oder wir haben C
eingenommen oder irgendwas richtig Dummes haben wir da als Witz gebracht. Das weiß ich noch,
wo wir die ganzen Fahnen gesehen haben und das wusste ich jetzt, okay Leute, da kann ich mich
nur dran erinnern, da hab ich auf die Uhr geguckt, da hab ich festgestellt, Mist, ich muss zum Hauptbahnhof.
Da bin ich Brandenburger Tor durchgelaufen durch diese Gärten und dann zum Hauptbahnhof. Das
Coole ist, dass das irgendwie alles so in Laufreichweite ist. Das fand ich nicht schlecht. Gut,
wahrscheinlich ist da auch mehr noch außen rum, wo man nicht hin muss, aber Brandenburger Tor hat
mir gereicht, mehr muss ich... achso, nee, Brandenburger Tor und Reichstag, genau, da läuft
sie dann ja auch vorbei. Das ist da, wo die Leute vor zwei Jahren irgendwie versuchten,
in die Treppe zu stürmen. An dem Tag, wo ich da war, war eigentlich so gut wie in toten Hosen.
Genau, Reichstag, Brandenburger Tor und dann zum Hauptbahnhof und mit Scheiben gefahren. Hat
mir gereicht, Kulturprogramm im Schnelldurchlauf. Fertig. Knobbers! Endlich mal ein Angebot für
mich. Ich mag Knobbers zwar nicht, aber immerhin mal was in die richtige Richtung, ja.
Du bist der einzige, die immer noch gucke, nice. Knobbers, nee, ich mag Knobbers nicht. Also ich
esse Knobbers schon, aber wenn ich die Auswahl hätte zwischen was, wo ich richtig Bock drauf
hätte und Knobbers, dann würde ich das nehmen. Knobbers. Schon was Gutes gefunden. Ehrlich gesagt,
nur Dinger, die man sich kaufen kann, wenn man sich, man muss sich selbst dazu quasi fast
schon überreden, das zu kaufen. Nee, also richtig so das Ding, wo ich sage, ey, da bin ich schaff
drauf. Sag mal, das Legotechnikzeug ist, hat auch jeglichen Bezug zur Realität verloren, oder? Mit
300 Euro. Ich habe früher, als ich klein war, sehr viel Legotechnik gebaut. Von Sportautos bis
Flugzeugen, das war die richtig komplizierten Dinger. Und ich weiß, dass die Dinger damals
schon richtig teuer waren. Da bin ich dann immer mit dem Opa einkaufen gegangen oder Opa Oma oder
meiner Mutter dabei, sind wir einkaufen gegangen und ich konnte mir dann was raussuchen und das hat
dann maximal, maximal 100, ich glaube, das war sogar noch Mac oder so gekostet. Also das ist ja im
Verhältnis zu damals ist das sogar, selbst wenn man das jetzt hochrechnet, immer noch krass teuer.
Ich meine 330 Euro normalerweise, das ist ja echt nicht normal. Ja, also wirklich,
das ist komplett Realitätsbezug. Ja, also nee. Warte mal, Hältersteine. Hältersteine habe ich
zufällig mal gesehen am Südbahnhof. Ich habe aber nichts gesagt. Ich kann mich noch, ich kann mich
noch gerade erinnern, als ich einmal mit meinem Opa Oma, da sollte ich mir für Weihnachten, die
waren ja wenigstens clever, die haben ja immer zu mir gesagt, such dir selbst aus und haben nicht
komische Sachen für mich gekauft. Und da sind wir Legotechnik gegangen, da waren wir in irgendeinem
Einkaufscenter oder so. Und dann haben die gesagt, hier guck mal, was willst du denn haben? Und die
waren der Ansicht, ich nehme nicht das teuerste und größte, ich nehme das, wo ich am meisten Bock
drauf habe zu bauen. Da lagen sie aber falsch. Das wussten sie bloß nicht. Und als sie nicht
hingeguckt haben, habe ich in einem Moment, kann mich heute irgendwie noch dran erinnern,
vielleicht habe ich mich danach schlecht gefühlt oder so. Keine Ahnung. In einem Moment, wo sie
nicht hingeguckt haben, habe ich mir drei Kisten rausgenommen, habe die nebeneinander gehalten und
habe festgestellt, was die größte Kiste ist und habe dann gesagt, ich will die größte Kiste haben.
Und die waren danach der Meinung, das weiß ich auch, Wanner macht dann ein, der hat sich nicht die
größte und teuerste Kiste rausgesetzt, der wollte am liebsten dieses Auto bauen. War halt größte,
größte und teuerste Kiste am Start. Richtig debatet. Das war, damals hat man das, glaube ich,
auch mit K geschrieben auch. Gab es mal Zeiten, wo man Lego Technik mit K geschrieben hat?
Rot Auto. Ja, das hier, das ist es. Das ist das. Moment, nee, das ist das nicht. Das Auto,
was ich hatte, da konntest du vorne so Lampen hoch und runter machen. Das ist dann ein Vorgänger
davon. Aber das ist sowas in die Richtung. Definitiv. Bloß, dass ich, ich konnte vorne
Scheinwerfer hoch und runter machen. Ja, ja, so sah das schon aus. So in der Richtung sah das
schon aus. Nur, dass das, wie gesagt, nur, dass man Scheinwerfer zu hoch und runter machen hat.
Du hast da Lampenzombos, ist das hier? Nee, wo sind denn die Lampenzombos? Hier, da, Lampenzombos
runterfahren, genau. Da, ja, das ist das. Ja, hier, doch, doch, das ist das. Ja, genau. Genau das.
Ja, irgendwie 120 Mack oder so hat es damals gekostet. Da habe ich eine ganze Weile dran
gebaut. Das war richtig cool. Es hat einen richtigen Motor gehabt hinten, also so ein
Fake-Lego-Motor, also keinen richtigen Motor, sondern in Lego-Teilen einen nachgebauten,
so mit Zylinder und so. Ich glaube nicht, dass das heute so viel wert ist. Die Teile sind ja
relativ 0815. Ja, genau, so einen Buggy hast du da normalerweise. Ich habe das auch alles noch,
aber die Teile sind ja 0815 hier. Und die Federn fand ich auch richtig geil, dass das quasi so
gefedert hat. Das war für mich richtig Massive Exploding Brain, Alter. Ja. Es hatte so keine
Gangschaltung innen drin. Ja. Da hatte ich unten im Kinderzimmer, hatte ich den ganzen Tisch voller
Lego. Ja, das war schon nice. Aber trotzdem, die haben mittlerweile komplett den Realitätsbezug
verloren. 300 Euro. Und ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, das nannte sich doch damals noch Lego
Technik mit K, oder? Ne, anscheinend nicht. Das ist das Auto. Genau das ist es. Und das
schreibt man auch mit C. Genau das ist das. Ich dachte immer, man hätte das mal mit K
dargeschrieben, aber anscheinend nicht. Pneumatik-Bugger hatte ich auch. Ich hatte Pneumatik-Bugger und
ich hatte ein Pneumatik-Schiff. Lego-Stells. Da konnte man den Kran ausfahren, das war
auch richtig nice. Also ich gehe davon aus, ohne Legosachen, ohne Lego Technik damals,
hätte ich mich nie für Computer und Bastelkram interessiert. Also man könnte quasi sagen,
ohne Lego würde ich heute nicht hier sitzen. Da gehe ich relativ stark von aus. Damit
habe ich angefangen zu basteln, um mich für so Mechaniksachen zu interessieren und später
dann auch für halt Computerkram, Elektroniksachen und rumgebasteln, was ich heute immer noch
gerne mache. Also ich denke, ohne Lego würde ich nicht hier sitzen. Ach guck mal, es gibt
wieder Webcams. Webcams waren ja relativ lange ausverkauft, weil die Leute alle Webcams fürs
Homeoffice gebraucht haben. Lokalessen, jawoll. Ach Bier, wer braucht denn Bier? Ich habe
unter Lokalessen verstanden. Es gibt was zu essen, aber die meinen mit Essen wahrscheinlich
die Stadt. Liebherr-Gefrierkühlschrank, 9,99 Euro, easy. Genau so ein, also nicht genau
so ein, aber von diesem Hersteller habe ich einen, aber ein bisschen älteren und der funktioniert
wunderbar. Deswegen sehe ich überhaupt nicht einen mehr, was Neues zu kaufen. Chat sagt
mal eine dumme Frage. Weiß jemand, wie man Steam-Spiele vollständig mit allem deinstalliert?
Was? Sorry, ich kann gerade immer richtig lesen. Weiß jemand, wie man Steam-Spiele vollständig
mit allem deinstalliert? Denn beim Update ist der Speicher vollgelaufen, seit dem Starten
des Spiels nicht mehr. Kannst du nicht einfach Rechtsklick uninstall machen? Die Updates installieren
sich doch alle in den Ordnerreihen, wo die Spiele liegen. Also wenn du das Spiel deinstallierst,
ist doch das Update auch weg. Die einzigen Sachen, die vielleicht hängen bleiben, sind
so Sachen wie Bad Company 2, Punkbuster oder sowas. Kann sich überhaupt noch jemand an
Punkbuster erinnern? Das war noch Zeiten, Leute, als Punkbuster die Anti-Cheat-Lösung
wieder Wahl war. Ich muss euch sagen, ich seh mir fast immer noch lieber als die ganzen
Root-Kids von heute. Allerdings muss man sagen, das war damals ja auch schon Windows-Service
mit Admin-Rechten. Das war quasi der Vorgänger der heutigen Anti-Cheat-Root-Kids. Es ist unglaublich
wie wenig Interessantes es gibt. Achso, ich wollte ja China-Tablets gucken. Von was für
einem Hersteller? Ich kann es doch nicht mal lesen. Was genau soll das bedeuten? E-Diff?
Warum hat der Typ dreimal den Play Store drauf? Hat der Photoshop China-Mann nicht so richtig
aufgepasst bei den Eigens? Okay, dieser Hersteller sagt mir absolut nichts. Ich weiß noch nicht
mal, wie man ihn schreibt. Genau, drei Shops um drei Sachen gleichzeitig zu installieren.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie man die überhaupt richtig schreibt. Persistent Power Supply?
Was ist das? Das erweckt ja den Anschein, als wäre das eine Kugel. Wo kommen wir denn
da hin? Das wird den Flatnursern aber nicht gefallen. Ist eh alles manipuliert. Zumindest
laut den ihrer Logik. Angeblich habe ich letztens wieder ein Video gehört. Angeblich hätte
die NASA auf ihrer Webseite stehen, dass die Erde flach ist. Ich habe da so meine Zweifel,
dass das stimmt. Zumindest im jeweiligen Kontext gesehen. Sicherlich nicht. Wir haben jetzt
mehrfach gesehen, dass es E-Ziff ist. Okay, das will ich mir gar nicht. Warum genau kriege
ich da irgendwelche komische Ein... Ach, da ist das Tablet drin, oder? Oh, Zertifikate.
Oh ja, jetzt ist ja alles gut. Guck mal, das VLC Logo ist auch am Start. Jetzt ist ja alles
gut. Ja, das ist bestimmt alles legit. Ich, Leute, jetzt mal ernsthaft. Also, ich will
letztendlich nicht unterstellen, dass die faken, aber dieses Bild von so Laborarbeit
oder was das ist, von so... Dieses Bild habe ich gefühlt schon 20 Mal gesehen. Es könnte
aber auch einfach so sein, dass die Bilder sich so ähnlich aussehen von diesen Keller-
Fließbandarbeiten-Dingern, dass ich das jetzt verwechsel. Am E-Code-Spot habe ich dieses
Bild schon 20 Mal gesehen. Genau das gleiche Bild. Paketsteuer. Unterstützungssprache. Alles
da. Ein Tablet, was ich mir nicht kaufe. Chinafabrik Stock Footage. Das glaube ich auch, dass
das Chinafabrik Stock Footage ist. Die Rückenlehnen sehen weird champ aus. Guck mal, mal schnell.
Warum sehen die Rückenlehnen weird champ aus? Ah, du meinst die nicht vorhandene Rückenlehnen?
Oh ja, das ist bestimmt richtig angenehm. Hier ohne vorhandene Rückenlehnen den ganzen
Dach. Ja, super, super. Und die hier auch. Und die sind so weit hinter, dass du dich...
Na ja, gut. Was muss man da an Ergonomie-Sachen denken? Das ist schon ergonomisch wahrscheinlich,
wenn da keiner vom Dach springt. Ist ergonomisch genug. Top Marken. Zeig mal her. Die Top Marken
bei Aliexpress. Two Twin Style. Lee Tokala. Na, wenn das mal nicht eine Top Marke ist.
Cutebot. Ah nee, Kubot. Ich kann das verstehen, dass die Leute lieber bei Wish bestellen
anstatt bei Aliexpress. Dabei ist es Schwachsinn. Aliexpress sieht für die meisten Leute, die
so westliche Shopping-Seiten gewöhnt sind, einfach nur nach krassem Scam aus. Die Sache
ist plus die, dass Wish der eigentliche Scam ist und nicht Aliexpress. Anker. Lee Tokala.
Technik. Technik. Auf geht's. Ich brauche Poggers Technik. Kann man anklicken, passiert
aber nix. Ach, das hier ist schon Technik. Alter, sind das hier irgendwelche... Das sind
auch Puppen, oder? Mein Gott, Aliexpress. Alter, das ist so weirdchamp, die Seite. Die ist
so weirdchamp teilweise. Ach, guck mal. Die guten Lee Tokala Akkus. P245. Ah, die wollten
wir doch schon immer mal haben, oder? China Akkus. Unbedingt. Was, der SSD für... Oh,
die 16 Euro SSD, die ist bestimmt auch richtig gut. Na gut, 120G. Der Rest nimmt sich auch
nicht so viel zu normalen Preisen. Ich kaufe auch keine China Akkus. Es gibt Sachen, die
müssen nicht sein und China Akkus gehören dazu. China Akkus brauche ich wirklich nicht.
Was haben denn die Chinesen noch zu bieten? Game Sir, Bluetooth. Ich bin mir ziemlich
sicher, dass du eigentlich nicht diese Xbox Button Anordnung und Benamung und Farben
machen darfst, wenn du nicht Microsoft bist und dir das irgendwie gekauft hast, dass du
das darfst. Aber das ist den Chinesen wahrscheinlich egal. Die sind nicht gekopiert. Sicher nicht.
Also Sony ist da richtig hinterher. Ich hätte jetzt erwartet, dass es bei Microsoft auch
so ist. Sind sie nicht? War ganz davon abgesehen, es wäre eh egal. Die Chinesen kopieren das
trotzdem. Ah, jetzt haben wir die Auswahl zwischen den Shops von Baseus, Lounge, nicht
lesbar, nicht lesbar, Xtool und Outtel. Achso, wir sind bei Autos. Da wollen wir nicht hin.
Also noch 2 cm weiter und mein Stream wäre jetzt wegen Monka Tost gebannt. Ich habe
immer so ein schlechtes Gefühl, wenn ich auf AliExpress scrolle. Es ist so viel Schwachsinn
dabei. Alter, guckt euch das mal an. Also wenn ihr dachtet, Amazon wäre schon viel und
schwachsinnig. Jetzt kommt AliExpress, die trumpfen jetzt richtig auf. Ich weiß zum
Beispiel schon mal gar nicht, was soll das überhaupt sein? Ich bin ja nicht unbewandt,
was Technik angeht, aber ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist. Ach, irgendein Flashgerät oder
keine Ahnung. Willst du keinen Teppich für 1 Cent? Ach doch, dicken Teppich für Wohnzimmer.
Einen dicken Teppich fürs Wohnzimmer, ja klar will ich den. Leute, ich habe euch aus Versehen
weggedrückt im Chat. MonkaS, gleich muss ich wieder aufmachen. So ihr seid wieder da, alles
gut. Ein dicker Teppich. Ich wette mit euch, wenn du diesen Teppich in die Wohnung legst,
das stinkt erst mal für 3 Monate dein Wohnzimmer, du kannst nicht mehr rein. Snapchat Filter
oder was ist da oben drüber? Leute, sind das irgendwie Snapchat Filter oder sowas in der
Richtung? Ja, super weich, mega quality. Wenn du da so einen Geigerzähler dran hältst,
hat es wahrscheinlich Ausschlag wegen irgendwelcher atomaren Versäugnungen oder so. Size Guide.
Guck mal, den Size Guide gibt es auch in Cacomodate. Chernobyl hat angerufen, die wollen ihren
Teppich zurück, so umgeverstellte ich mir das auch. Guck mal, gibt es schon Röntgenbilder
oder was auch immer das ist. Okay, wir kaufen jetzt den fettesten Teppich aus China in
blau. In blau? In, in bunt, das der ist gut. Ey, ohne Scheiß, den finde ich wirklich cool.
Nicht, dass ich ihn kaufen würde, aber überhaupt nicht. Das ist ja fast schon RGB Teppich.
Oder aus Spanien? Ach, ich muss gar, ich muss den Preis aus, nee, das passt doch. Ach,
den gibt es nicht in Spanien. Den gibt es aber in Spanien. Guck mal hier, ich kann den
Teppich aus Spanien bestellen für 26 Euro, für nur 4,57 Versand oder aus Russland. Ja,
wunderbar. Super. Das, äh, warum 4,25? Ach so, der kleine wahrscheinlich. Der kleine
Teppich für 2,94 Euro, auf geht's. Den kleinen gibt es aber nur aus China. Ab wann gibt es
ihn in Spanien? Ah ja, ab hier gibt es ihn in Spanien. Okay. Was ein Blödsinn. Hör mal
auf. Okay, AliExpress. Tiefe Welle, Verschluss, Perücke. Alles klar. Tiefe Welle, das...
Ich frage mich gerade, was die uns im Original damit sagen wollten. Locken? Locken? Könnte
das sein? Locken? Tiefe Welle? Wahrscheinlich. Sterneprojektor. Samsung Evo, ja, die gibt
es bei uns auch. Da brauch ich den AliExpress bestellen. Hey, das sind die, die ich für
Weihnachtsbaum hab, oder? Sind das RGB? Nee. Nee, dann hab ich die nicht. Was bin ich
überhaupt sehend hier bei AliExpress? Was ist das? Ist das ein Massagegerät oder was
ist... Nee, das ist ein... Azika. Zum Wendehochklettern. Was, was zum Teufel ist da wieder los bei den
Arten, Mann? Das ist ein Azika zum Wendehochklettern. Guck mal, das ist auf den Mount Everest,
Leute. Auf den Mount Everest besucht Karl S. oben, wenn es oben ist. Es gibt so viel
Müll, ja, das stimmt schon. Spodermann, genau, Spodermann Azika. Zeigt, dass bloß nicht
da ist. Oje, das ist doch was, was sie auch in Battlefield einbauen könnten. Ich dachte,
man darf die nicht auf blöde Ideen bringen, ja, das stimmt.
BTF Lightning, von denen hab ich schon auf Amazon-Dinger bestellt. Die haben wir auch
im Shop in Deutschland. Die sind cool, die Dinger. Das sind so LED-Dinger mit so einem
Diffusor drauf, die ganz eng sind. Das finde ich wirklich cool. Da siehst du nämlich überhaupt
nicht mehr die einzelnen LEDs. Das finde ich hat was. Brauche ich aber trotzdem nicht.
How to Ressourcenverschwendung China Edition. Die haben das auch gelernt mittlerweile. Wartet
es mal ab. Aktuell ist es ja so, die Chinesen hauen schon am meisten so Emissionen raus,
aber trotzdem ist der Lebensstandard in China noch nicht so hoch wie bei uns. Wartet mal
ab, bis die Chinesen mal angekommen sind bei uns, dann ist eh vorbei. Dann ist der Ofen
aus. Oder, weiß ich auch nicht, ob man aussagen kann. Der An ist der eigentlich eher. Was
sehe ich hier wieder? Ich weiß auf den meisten Bildern nicht mal, was ich hier sehe. Ich
weiß immer noch nicht, was ich hier sehe. Was sehe ich hier? Ach Ballons. Ballons. Also
es gibt so viele Bilder bei AliExpress. Achja, 100 iPhone Hüllen, auch gut. High Quality
iPhone Hüllen. Kriegst wahrscheinlich Ausschlag, wenn du dran greifst. Da gibt es einen Akku,
ein ziemlich fetten Akku, wenn ich mir das angucke. 280 Amperestunden, das ist schon
ein bisschen was. Das ist ungefähr 15 Mal mehr als die normalen Handyakkus. Aber weiß
ich jetzt auch nicht, wozu man das braucht. Ist ja auch größer. Pokémon Karten. Bestimmt,
bestimmt legit, Leute. Bestimmt, bestimmt legit. Das sind bestimmt originale Pokémon
Karten bei AliExpress, ja. Um Kosten ist alles 1 Cent. Pogasmon, ja. Bestimmt überhaupt
kein Fake. Sind die Texte eigentlich chinesisch? Ich würde gerne reinzoomen können. Ah, die
Texte sind chinesisch. Nee, halbe halbe so. Magst du, mir wäre das auch egal, ob die
Fake sind. Letztendlich ist ja nur die Frage, wie gut ist der Fake? Wenn der Fake gut genug
ist, dann wird es mich auch nicht jucken. Aber der Pokémon Karten Hype ist schon wieder
vorbei, oder? Das war ja vor einem halben Jahr oder so hat ja jeder Pokémon Karten
gestellts auf Twitch und YouTube. Zur gleichen Zeit, wo Sus gespielt wurde, ist glaube ich
vorbei, ne? Lucky Bag. Ohje. Reste Verwertung auf AliExpress. Jawoll. Du kriegst random,
du kriegst random einfach in den Beutel geschickt mit Sachen drin. Es ist ja so schon nichts
dabei, was ich mir kaufen will. Und jetzt kriege ich einfach einen random Beutel mit
random Shit. Oh nein. Und Leute, ihr glaubt doch nicht ernsthaft, dass da wirklich Staubsaugerroboter,
was ist das hier überhaupt? Und Kameras und Notebooks drin sind. Das sind 3D VR Brillen.
Da ist einfach der größte Schrott aller Zeiten drin. Farbe. Random, ein PC, das ist
doch nicht random, Leute. Das ist doch nicht random. Das ist einfach billige Resteverwertung.
Kann mir doch keiner erzählen, dass die random da was reinschmeißen würden. Vom Laptop
bis zum USB Stick. 2-7 random Giftbox. 100% Electric Products. Ach, hier ist er. Meine
Güte, was ein Schrott, Alter. Aber man muss ihn lassen, also erfinderisch sind sie. Erfinderisch
sind sie hier wirklich. Also wenn ich so eine Überraschungslootbox will, da gibt es ja
mittlerweile genug Dienste, die das in Deutschland auch machen, wo du dir dann sogar noch ungefähr
das Themengebiet aussuchen kannst. Also anscheinend sind Perücken bei AliExpress voll angesagt
gerade. Guck mal hier. 500 erwachsene Einweg. Ich wollte auch schon immer 500 erwachsene
Einweg kaufen. Das ist ja fast schon Menschenhandel hier. Sind das Originale? Das sind keine
FP2, das ist Fake. Wenn schon, denn schon. Also Perücken scheinen in China wirklich gut
zu gehen. Was? Warme, starke TV mit kaputte Pullover, Decke, Uni6, Riesentasche. Die
Chinesen. Was ist denn da schon wieder los? Die Chinesen, Alter. Das sieht so hängen geblieben
aus. Dieses Bild, finde ich, sieht mega hängen geblieben aus. Guck mal, wir können sogar
ein Video zu angucken. Die Dinger sind mega geil oder Chat kennt sich aus. Das ist doch
immer die gleiche Animation, die da immer wieder kommt, oder? Wahnsinn, was es alles
gibt. Hey, die Maus kommt mir bekannt vor. Habt ihr die Maus nicht auch heute schon mal
irgendwo gesehen? Die kommen mir äußerst bekannt vor. Die haben wir ganz am Anfang
bei Amazon schon gesehen. Die Chinesenbilder verwirren mich auch immer. Die ist so silent,
dass du quasi neben deinem schlafenden Kind auf die Maus klicken kannst. Alternativ wäre
auch, vielleicht nicht neben deinem schlafenden Kind am Laptop arbeiten. Wäre auch möglich.
Guck mal hier mit Triple, Triple USB Anschluss. Noch mehr Perücken. Also das scheint echt
der Renner in China zu sein. Noch mehr Perücken. Was ist das? Ach, das ist zum Heben. Damit
hebt man Dinger hoch. Das sieht noch auf den ersten Blick blöde aus. Damit hebt man
Dinger hoch. Aber ob das so stabil ist, wenn das nur Plastik ist? Wird auch was ernsthaftes
gekauft. Ich hab's versucht. Es gibt nichts. Noch mehr Perücken. Was ist denn? Alter, was
ist denn mit den Chinesen und den Perücken los? Ist doch immer das gleiche. Model. Guckt
mal. Glaub ich zumindest. Ja. Jaja. Elektronische Kettensäge für 10 Euro. Wer will, wer hat
noch nicht? Die ist auch so lang. Damit kannst du bestimmt richtig viel sägen. Und Spanien.
Das reicht doch nicht mal fürs Bein. So klein ist das. Kommst du nicht durch. Karaoke Verstärker.
Jawoll. Moment, ist das ein USB Hub mit für jedem einzelnen USB einen Schalter? Puh.
Man könnte das USB Gerät auch ausstecken. Aber da könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass es
vielleicht in irgendwelchen Anwendungsszenarien, auf die ich jetzt gerade nicht komme, durchaus
sinnvoll sein könnte. Aber richtig cool wäre das, wenn man das Remote schalten könnte,
oder? Also wenn man das Remote schalten könnte und flashen könnte, dann wär ich dabei. Heute
schon was Gutes gefunden, ehrlich gesagt. Nee. Nur Sachen, wo ich mit sehr viel Geld
ausgebe wille es bestellen würde. 6 Euro Wifi Repeater mit immer. Was sieht man dann
hier wieder? Was? Ein tragbarer Drucker? Mit App? Wie darf ich mir das denn vorstellen?
Ist das ein Einwegdrucker und ist der danach dann leer oder? Ah, Thermopapier. Ja, aber
das ist dann nur schwarz-weiß, oder? Ist das auch in Farbe? Nee, das ist nur schwarz-weiß.
Na gut. Okay, das könnte sogar funktionieren. Elektrische Kleidung, Fußpillenrasierer. Fast
eine Beschreibung, Alter. Elektrische Kleidung, Fußpillenrasierer. Alles klar. Jetzt wissen
wir Bescheid. LED-Scheinwerfer-Fischerei. Sind das Skier? Sind das Skier für das Notebook?
Das sind Skier fürs Notebook. Also es ist ein Stand, aber es sieht aus wie Ski. Notebook
in Abfahrthaltung. Die Musik ist gerade irgendwie merkwürdig. Mein Gott, was ein Schrott. Es
ist ja unglaublich. Chat, hat noch irgendjemand eine Idee für einen guten Shop, wo wir was
gucken? Wir wollten bei Alternate noch gucken. Alternate. So. GeForce 3060 für 760 Euro
und ausverkauft. Und eine 2060 für 10 Euro weniger. Die Schnapper sind ja wieder hier
am Start. Die Musik nervt mich gerade. Ich brauche irgendwas anderes. Ne, nein, nein.
Moment, nicht AliExpress. Alternate. Cool Blue. Doch, das hatten wir letztens schon.
Ok, Tagesstil. Ja, zeig her. Ach ja, das Barbie-Caprio. Excellent, excellent. Schleichhors.
Warum ist das kein Stellschorz? Oh, SSDs. Jetzt verwirrende ich mich aber auch. Ist es
jetzt Tagesstil? Was ist denn da jetzt der Unterschied dazwischen? Das gilt für die
ganze Woche oder wie? Das ist der Black-Week-Deal. Black-Week. Ok, das ist auch maximal verwirrend.
Außer als geht es auf Tagesstil. Bäm. Ist doch auch alles Müll. Also, sei dann, man
braucht einen neuen Backofen. Seit wann hat denn Alternate Backöfen? Haben die sowas
schon länger? Ach, hier war ich vorhin drinnen. Ey, 4 8TB Platten. Bäm, ba ba bäm. Wenn
man es braucht. Stell mir gleich das Barbie-Caprio. RGB-RAM. Also, RAM ist ja aktuell, glaube
ich, von allen Teilen noch am günstigsten. Ja, ich hatte früher Sepsim am Nass, 3WD,
10TB. 8TB hatte ich. Oder 10. Ne, 10. 10 hatte ich. SSD scheint auch relativ günstig
zu sein. Ja, ist so. Leute, es gibt nur Müll. Was machen wir denn da jetzt? Ich gucke jetzt
noch mal kurz Chat, ob ich irgendwas übersehen habe. Ah, da wird es wieder alles timeouten
gelassen. Ich glaube, hier Wubblos gibt es hier irgendwas. Chain-Lo am Spam. Chain-Lo
am Spam. Ne. Gibt heute nichts. Gut, also Leute, ich habe keine Ahnung, was ich machen
soll. Es gibt ja wirklich nur Schrott, maximal Schrott, also extremster Schrott. Bei Amazon,
bei AliExpress und sonst auch nix. Ja, wirklich komplett für n Arsch. 32G ist nicht verkehrt.
Ich habe auch 32G, das einzige, was ich aufgerüstet habe am Rechner. 32G. Wo steht es denn überhaupt
da? Guckt hier. Die Hälfte, die Hälfte ist schon used. Guck mal, ich brauche hier Tabs,
ich brauche da Tabs. Was heißt schon, was der Browser für den RAM braucht? Wurdest
du eigentlich schon mal auf Twitch gebannt? Nein, wurde ich nicht. Wie kommst du drauf?
Pass auf, jetzt kommt, haha, ich arbeite eigentlich für Twitch, morgen wirst du gebannt, null
oder irgendwie sowas. Das ist dann die gleiche Story wie früher. Mein Vater arbeitet bei
Microsoft erbanntisch. Wir hatten vorhin gar keinen richtigen Toss. Strike habe ich, ja,
ich habe einen Strike, weil ich es mal gewagt habe, eine Apple Presse zu streamen und zu
kommentieren. Da hat Tim Apple gesagt, nope, das geht aber nicht. Wie kannst du für uns
nur kostenlose Werbung machen? Da streiken wir dich jetzt für. Welche Keynote, weiß
schon gar nicht mehr, was das war vor einem Jahr oder so ist das her. Nee, die kannst
du mittlerweile überall angucken, aber Apple mag das anscheinend nicht, das zu streamen.
Jeder andere hat damit kein Problem. Microsoft kannst du alles, was die machen, streamen,
das juckt die überhaupt nicht. Sony juckt das auch nicht. EA, Activision, Ubisoft, was
auch immer alle interessiert das nicht, nur Apple. Bald Weihnachtsbastler streamen, was
wollen wir denn basteln an Weihnachten? Habe ich irgendwas schon angekündigt, was ich selbst
vergessen habe? Was basteln wir denn an Weihnachten? Hast du selbst eigentlich Apple Geräte? Ja,
ich habe ein iPhone, ich habe ein iPad. Und jetzt kommen die Leute wieder aus dem Weg
Geringverdiener, aber ich habe auch Android Geräte. Ich habe insgesamt mittlerweile 13
Tablets und Smartphones und ich glaube die Hälfte davon ist Android, aber davon benutze
ich aktuell eigentlich regelmäßig nur zwei Stück, drei Stück, wenn man mal das Shield
TV mitzählt. Der Rest ist zwei iPads, zwei iPhone 11 und ein iPhone SE von, also erste
Generation. Also sind im Endeffekt gerade sieben Geräte im Einsatz. Nein, das Repair
Getöns, also ja doch, das Repair Getöns habe ich mitbekommen, die hat es sich noch komplizierter
gemacht haben. Oder was meinste, mit Displays, die du nicht mehr wechseln kannst und sowas.
Welche Frage habt ihr denn? Rust an Weihnachten? Nö, das haben wir nicht gesagt. Ach stimmt,
die Weihnachts Emotes müssen wir nochmal, ich würde mal sagen, die mache ich am Sonntag,
weil am Sonntag ist erster Advent. Wir müssen ja KegW und solche Sachen noch durch die Weihnachtsversion
austauschen, stimmt? Ne, das habe ich nicht mitbekommen, da bin ich mal gespannt ob die
das machen. Dein Emote? Stimmt, du kriegst auch noch ein Emote, meine Güte hier, die
Leute sind ja wieder voll auf Zack. Die merken sich aber alles. Leute, in Anbetracht
der Tatsache, dass schon spät ist und dass es nichts, aber auch gar nichts irgendwie gibt,
was ich heute gesehen hätte, was mich reizen würde zu kaufen, glaube ich, hör mal jetzt
auf zu gucken, gibt da gar nichts. Ich gucke jetzt mal schnell durch, ob ich irgendjemand
hosten kann, irgendjemand von kleineren, denen ich follow, die es nötig haben.
Ne, alles klar Leute, wir sehen uns dann spätestens Sonntag früh, aber wahrscheinlich morgen
auch. Ich habe ja Urlaub bis Januar. Eigentlich, ich habe jetzt fast jeden Tag gestreamt, Leute,
ich habe fast jeden zweiten Tag ein YouTube-Video gemacht und fast jeden Tag gestreamt, ging
voll ab, diesmal geht es ja richtig rund hier. Oh ne, ne, ne, bestimmt nicht mehr, war ja
auch nicht. Ich werde erstmal kein Battlefield 2042 spielen, das macht mir einfach keinen
Bock. Vielleicht gucke ich mir mal ein paar Portal-Spielmodi an, wenn es jetzt Rush gibt.
Haben wir letztens erst gemacht, ich wüsste jetzt auch nicht, was ich Neues machen soll.
Outro-Musik, YouTube hat das Video gelöscht mit meiner Outro-Musik. Wieso so lange Urlaub,
nur weil ich zu lange Urlaub noch übrig habe. Aber Leute, ich mache jetzt Schluss, wir sehen
uns. Bis morgen oder übermorgen, machts gut, see you.